all right we're back hopefully that [ __ ]
doesn't happen again
no idea where to go we we streamed with
this
laptop for what nearly six months
without any kind of problem
and then all of a sudden it just started
it doesn't do it every time but because
sometimes you can go
as soon as you can go six hours yeah
sometimes you can go like six hours and
it doesn't drop sometimes you go to like
20 minutes like today
and then it just knocks out so what
happened so
like i said that first part i'll
probably just label it pre-show because
we didn't even talk about a billionaire
so i don't want it like i don't want it
titled that because we didn't even get
into it
but you know what i mean because we were
still talking about appreciation yeah i
think we pretty much uh
covered everything for the uh for the
warm-up i think so yeah because we
talked about chantals we talked about
this oh i gotta go get a new tire
tomorrow yeah i forgot about that
yes maybe we'll make an appointment
so we'd have to sit around wait all that
time i mean you still gotta wait if you
make an appointment but it might be like
better than not
you're right we'll get entire kingdom
tomorrow i was gonna do it on the way
home today but i didn't know how long it
would take and
i was just kind of like i don't know
yeah you know
had to do the show so i didn't want to
be sitting around entire kingdom all
afternoon
but yeah so anything else we need to
address
are we still going no okay okay
so let's get to this so here's what
happened i know that these two topics
have
absolutely nothing to do with one
another but
what ended up happening is that the
patreon
topic poll was a tie and sometimes in
that situation depending on what the
topic is like sometimes i'll be like oh
we'll just talk about it on the side
track show
but this week i kind of thought well
these two topics are really kind of
cool and need their own you know kind of
you know story about them so i was like
maybe i'll just throw them both on the
same show you know they don't have
anything to do with each other
so i'm like is that weird i don't know
whatever but i'm not
like past caring at this point so what i
was gonna do at first
so i wanted to talk about amelia earhart
i was gonna save that for a second
because i was like oh like the
the other cult that we're going to be
talking about is like so [ __ ] up that
amelia earhart will be a palette
cleanser
but now i think i'm going to switch the
thing i think we'll talk about amelia
earhart first
okay because i think that the cult [ __ ]
is so [ __ ] up that we're gonna need
some liquor
okay um to okay so the crazy thing about
this like a lot of people know about
amelia earhart right
and we'll talk a little bit about that
what we think happened to her and all
this other stuff
but a couple people had recommended that
we talk about the anthill
kids cult and it's weird because when i
was
researching one of our other cult shows
i can't remember which one it was
i came across them and i was like man i
never heard of them
and then i kind of read about it and
it's like what the [ __ ] and i was just
kind of like man we need to do a show
about that and then some people
recommended it
so i finally got around to doing it i
don't understand
why the anthill kids aren't better known
because the leader of that [ __ ]
did some straight up [ __ ]
torture porn movie [ __ ] i mean
i was like i have a strong stomach right
and i was like reading some of this
stuff and i was like
i was like that i was like this is like
unbelievable
they have made a movie about it called
savage messiah
um but it's french language so i don't
know it's a it might be a french movie
or french canadian because he's french
canadian yeah i'm here
for i just said okay uh yeah canada yeah
it was canada
okay um back in the 70s and 80s all
right that's why i probably would never
be
here but it's just but you would think
that something this egregious
like the [ __ ] that the
well the name doesn't have anything to
do with anything that they did all right
but some of the [ __ ] that this dude did
was just like
i could i can't believe it's like real
you know what i mean
well we'll get to it so i i said well
you know what it's it's so [ __ ] up
that i'm going to save it till
last because then i want like your
drunken reactions to the [ __ ] like when
i tell you about it
see she's using me as the clown
she wants me
i stand in as the as the uninformed
audience even though a lot half the time
i know the cases
but we'll see well and a lot of times uh
people in the audience know the cases
too
but you know they just want to hear us
like [ __ ] riff on them yeah
coming why are they really far behind
yeah
i'm like well i'm 10 seconds behind
normally thank you zach
i found out amelia was one of the first
celebrities to start a clothesline with
her name on it
and i always thought she was stylish as
[ __ ] yeah she was like a really really
cool chick and i was like she was like a
real pioneer man
and it almost seemed like she wasn't
even doing it um
i don't i don't necessarily want to say
she wasn't doing purposefully because
she knew what she was doing
but she was just like so ahead of her
time in so many ways
and she was just like so yeah okay about
it like she was just like being regular
and she would totally fit in nowadays
but back then it was like
kind of scandalous but then on the other
people were like us back then
yeah but then on the other hand like she
it's weird because she was doing a lot
of [ __ ] that like women weren't supposed
to do quote unquote
but then she was like super super famous
also and everybody loved her but just
because she was so
charming and she was real humble she
wasn't like super arrogant about her
[ __ ] or anything like that she just
really really loved to fly planes and
that's what she wanted to do
and everybody just thought it was kind
of awesome that she was doing it she
didn't really like being famous all that
much
you know she seemed like kind of a
little bit not i don't know she i'd say
she was introverted but she seemed a
little bit kind of
uncomfortable with the attention yeah
you know
she just wanted to fly and do like
daredevil [ __ ] that's all
yeah but yeah so i guess we'll talk
about that first do you know um
do you know anything about amelia
earhart or yeah he's missing
well everybody knows yeah listen and
they found they found some
they found some stuff over but i don't
want to spoil it yeah
she crashed but i think she survived it
but i think
then she died yeah that's what i think
happened because
she knew how to navigate we're kind of
getting ahead of ourselves though
don't you want to get to the story yeah
all right she's already asking me where
she is
i didn't no i didn't ask well somebody
the tv drugger said are y'all going to
talk about the conspiracy
that amelia earhart came back under an
assumed name yeah i'll get into some of
the theories about it well there were
some people that said that the japanese
saw her
and captured her that's another that's
another theory yeah that's another
there are there's a lot of different i
don't think that happened either but
then yeah
spoiler alert but um i do yeah there's i
think i have like eight or nine
different theories of people some of
them are like related
but i don't know i was watching some
more recent
uh documentaries about it there was one
uh
that was on naked science which i guess
is on
was on the science channel and i think
it was just from a couple of years ago
maybe 2017 or 2018 or something
and they were pretty convinced that they
knew what had happened
like you know because of some new
information so i might get into that in
a little bit uh
too but uh yeah so
let's talk a little bit about amelia
earhart the queen of the air
as she was called or lady lindy which
kind of pissed her off
because she was like the second person
because she you know charles lindbergh
had done that circumnavigating the globe
thing and she would have been the second
person to do it
um so she was just kind of like you know
why can't i just be like me instead of
being like oh the lady version of that
dude you know what i mean
it's funny how you said that you know
she her attitudes were like that of a
modern person
like any like and kind of
kind of fits in with what i was saying
last week
the way we live right now a lot of you
people even listening
is the way back in the early 1900s only
celebrities lived like us
they didn't have air conditioning air
conditioning didn't come too much later
the average person who could just be
just totally broke dick
today okay living up in some you know
some shack somewhere actually has access
to a better standard
of living than a medieval lord would
have had
yeah people don't realize that that's
how much we've
that's how much we've advanced actually
poverty has been eliminated
if you looked at it from the point of
view of the medieval era
there is no poverty fourth person even a
bum on the street
here all right had more
than the average person in the middle
medieval area era or had a probably
better quality of life i mean they sit
around get high
you couldn't do that medieval period
they were working you to death
well and the thing about uh the medieval
period too was uh
no modern medicine no modern medicine no
human rights
get to work out there you know [ __ ]
with that scythe and cut down that wheat
or we kill you oh by the way i'm gonna
[ __ ] your daughter
that's literally what that [ __ ] was
about yeah there wasn't really anything
you could do about it
i mean they didn't really have any legal
redress they didn't have any anything
nope and you're in bondage tied to the
land if the lord came in and bought the
land
you came with it he owned your ass too
yeah you know i mean so like i said
nobody's saying that uh you know a bomb
nowadays has it good i'm just saying
that it
relatively back then that period right
yeah i mean
yeah obama can lay around and do nothing
you couldn't do that in a medieval era
they kill you you you only existed to
serve the lord we're not talking about
jesus we're talking about the landlord
that's why you were there again you
stepped out of line they killed you
well yeah because you were just another
one yeah
yeah they didn't really get uh on board
with that whole human rights thing until
the enlightenment really no humans had a
right to get to get their heads chopped
off that's
the right you had pretty much they're
like you got a right to like make more
money there to serve the lord and die
on his command if you [ __ ] up he just
killed you yeah
no rights well yeah that not really uh
not not much conception of people as
valuable in and of themselves you know
you had divine rights but that was only
that was only
lords and aristocrats and that was the
divine right to rule over everyone
because god
said so man said i could
that's called divine right i got all
these knights and warriors
so god says i'm here to [ __ ] you up
yeah if i wasn't here to [ __ ] you up
then that would be against god and we
know that everything happens because of
god's will
so it's god's will that i take your wife
qed
yeah yeah it's just mike makes right god
said so
man said i could man said you messed
that closet
yeah yeah in the clouds
i swear to god the first i think i
mentioned this when we talked about that
show
but i was like the first time i watched
that episode when he was doing all that
she was explaining like all the stuff
that he did i'm like so he's just like a
regular little boy then or
what i mean he wasn't doing anything
like a closet
no i mean but it's not that weird for
like little boys to do gross [ __ ] like
that
i have brothers i was running there
peeing in a closet i never peed in the
closet
my brother once crazy my brother once
peed on a cheese ball and then ate it
how old was he i don't know
he's pretty pretty he was 17. yeah no he
was pretty young
he was even still a kid
[Laughter]
but yeah i mean kids do grow [ __ ] that's
kind of that's kind of their thing
but yeah so let's talk about amelia
earhart okay okay
so uh she was born in kansas in 1897.
now when she was a kid i love that she
had a sister
i can't remember the sister's real name
was but i remember that her
nickname was pidge and i just i don't
know why i remember that i just thought
that was so funny that that like that
was her sister's name was pidge
so i mean even from a very young age
amelia
was you know nowadays they'd call her a
tomboy yes kids played more outside back
then
obviously because they didn't have video
games
but even for that era she was pretty
you know rough and tumble she you know
played a lot of sports um you know she
liked cars like working on cars she
liked
mechanics she was all that kind of stuff
now
you know there's a lot of stuff about
like her childhood and stuff but i don't
really think i need to go too much into
that because most people just want to
know about
her going missing and like theories
about it so we'll kind of
just skim over that but uh so she
actually served in world war
one she was a nurse's aide for the red
cross that was in toronto
she was actually working as a nurse's
aide during the
1918 spanish flu pandemic
interestingly and during that time
period she got like really really sick
um i think she got pneumonia and like
some other [ __ ] too and it took her like
a year like to get over that she was
like convalescing in hospitals back and
forth she got all kind of [ __ ] up
but she was alright after that now she
sort of
she got interested in flying when she
was
pretty young i think she used to go out
and like um there was an airfield
near where she lived and she would go
out and watch the
royal flying horror train it was like in
toronto and she would watch them flying
and she just thought that was the
coolest [ __ ] ever
so she wanted to learn to fly a plane so
she actually went
uh back to the us after the war she went
to
columbia university actually as a
pre-med student
um but you know she didn't finish
because she ended up taking her first
airplane ride
in december of 1920 and was like
this [ __ ] right here is what i want to
do like with my life i want to fly
planes
yeah here's the context people in case
you don't have the context
the airplane kind of appeared out of
nowhere just within a few
few years so at the time that it first
appeared
it was the height of technology that was
high-tech [ __ ]
because you'd think it would be easy to
build that you know but there's a lot of
stuff you have to know
you have to understand about pip prop
pitch
what's the best way to make a a wing
cross section you know how do you get
lift off of a wig
that was a wright brothers that figured
that out and they didn't figure it out
by
building it per se they built things
like wind tunnels
and put tape on things and tried to
figure out how airflow worked
that was really the only reason why the
wright brothers were the first ones to
fly
they had other guys trying to do it for
a couple about a decade before them
and when you looked at their machines
they were heavier more powerful
looks like maybe they would fly they
were in general
kind of airplane shaped a lot of them
but they didn't know about
prop pitch and wing cross section
to get lift they didn't know about
lifting bodies
so you know that was something you could
only do through testing and scientific
testing in wind tunnels which that's
what the wright brothers started with
wind tunnel
testing all right and what's funny
is that the technology that they were
using was based on bicycles
they were bicycle makers the bicycle was
the highest
expression of technology at that time
really which is funny to think about but
yeah yeah
uh and it it was bicycle technology
cable
cable controlled cable powered controls
or
cable do contour what do they call it oh
[ __ ]
yeah the control surfaces were all
powered connected with cables
that was like a slightly a bicycle
technology
there was a lot of chain technology like
chains running off an engine to drive a
propeller
that was new the canvas stretched over
the wood in certain ways it was
and things like spokes spokes in in in
wheels
all right that was all the spoke was a
pretty high-tech
concept and things like uh inflatable
tires
another high-tech concept see it was
best if you had that kind of stuff
and then you knew about aerodynamics so
they were able to fly
but that if you looked at that right
flyer it was like a
it used wing warping which is a [ __ ]
bad way of doing it
was controlled by cables but it was just
a bad way of doing it
and then a few years later there was
world war one and there were fighter
planes with damn machine guns on the top
of them and it just happened fast
and it happened faster than the average
person
out in the middle of the country could
deal with
you know in in in under a decade
which is crazy to think about because
probably a decade or two before
people would have still been talking
about oh heavier than air flight is
impossible
and then all of a sudden people are
doing it yeah and then they had machines
flying around
shooting at [ __ ] people and whatnot
and then really
world war ii was just a continuation of
world war one
and you can see how quickly this
technology developed
at the end of world war ii there were
already jets there were already guided
missiles
okay they weren't in common usage but
they existed the germans were working on
them and rockets
so the world wars accelerated technology
probably maybe almost a century just in
a a few decades
yeah i'd probably count i'd count the
30s as really when it started so yeah a
few decades
amazing it is yeah and you'd had people
out in the country here in the united
states
pre-television you might had radio and
you had newspapers
a lot of people had never seen an
airplane they just kind of heard about
it
if you had one you could fly into town
and make a lot of money with it giving
people rides and
doing acrobatics and putting on air
shows
so amelia earhart's jumping on this
again it's golden age when it was new
and everybody was really excited about
it it would be the equivalent of
maybe like space flight that'd be well
yeah
it was almost exactly the same thing as
that cutting edge of space flight right
now is getting to mars
so she would be kind of like the
equivalent of being like the first woman
to
go to mars on her own in her own
spaceship
that's what we're talking about yeah i
mean that's definitely i mean he was
famous like all over the world yeah
and the thing about it i don't know why
i just remembered this but that naked
science uh documentary
that i was watching about her they
actually had a woman on there
who wanted to replicate not her
circumnavigation of the globe
which sadly she did not come back from
but she wanted to do
um the cross-country flight that she did
like several years
previously in the same plane so she had
there's only one of those planes
remaining
like they didn't make that many of them
back then like the plane that she uh
used to fly around
fly across country and uh so this woman
did it
and she was talking about she's like you
know
back in the oldest you this is like the
1930s it's like these planes
didn't have stabilizers they didn't have
you know you didn't have gps you didn't
have anything like that she's like
flying this plane across the country is
like a full-time job you can't
she's like you you can't sleep you can't
do anything so like you you have to keep
like everything instruments and stuff
yeah you have to she's like and
you know turbulence comes along it
starts like shaking all over the place
it's like you can't
it doesn't have like all the instruments
that we have nowadays they're like it's
very very much like fly by the cedar
pants kind of [ __ ] yeah and in world war
one
the motors they were using to power
those aircraft wouldn't even
if you looked at the horsepower and the
torque
and then the weight they were so heavy
for such a small amount of power that
they actually made
they wouldn't even made a decent
motorcycle engine
and they were [ __ ] powering fighter
aircraft with them that
carrying machine guns and everything i
mean you got to think that people that
piloted planes
amelia earhart charles lindbergh
everybody like that that piloted
airplanes back in the early days of
flight with i mean these were
you know by today's standards they
didn't have yeah i mean they didn't like
have
any modern instruments they have
anything you had to have [ __ ] giant
brass balls yeah it was just like a to
get up in the [ __ ] air like thousands
of feet above the earth and that [ __ ]
these rickety little [ __ ] wooden
canvas contraptions wooden canvas or
wood
wouldn't get my ass metal no way sheet
metal surfaces
and it was just a shape with some
control surfaces
and a motor is stuck in the front that
wouldn't even make a decent
ford taurus motor really that like that
yeah the propeller stuck on the end of
it i mean you could literally go in your
garage and if you
you could build one of those if you had
the tools it would be well yeah like i'm
gonna put the car motor in that
that's essentially what they work yeah
the plane that she flew around the world
in or that she almost flew around the
world in because it's like it's sad
because she disappeared but she almost
made it she was on the last leg
that plane its top speed was 85 miles an
hour
which is [ __ ] mind-blowing i bet you
the motor only made about 50 or 60
horsepower
probably yeah i don't know with a
horsepower offhand but but i
was i i saw some [ __ ] that said it only
185 miles an hour yeah
how does it even stay aloft that's that
kills me if i remember correctly like
a dr7 a poker dr7 which is like one of
the best world war ii fighters i think
the motor only made 45 horsepower
i i think like i said
my build motorcycle in there makes 103
and that motor weighs like
one quarter of the weight just the motor
one quarter of that way
and you know more than twice that power
about
yeah more than twice so you could pull
that motor out
and put my motorcycle engine in it and
then and the [ __ ] plane had been a
lot lighter and a lot faster
yeah yeah with more power and the thing
about her flight too was she left a lot
of [ __ ] behind
um you know for weight purposes like to
make it as light as possible
um dc was saying that's why they had
such rapid progress too lots of room for
improvement
i think a lot of people don't realize i
was reading a book or an article about
this not too long ago
and it wasn't it was kind of talking
about technological progress but it was
also talking about stuff like
um people that uh broke records
like in sports and stuff and they're
like you know why is there so many
records like and
back in the old days and now there's not
so many i'm like well because we're
hitting
the wall of like humans back then it's
like
we didn't have all the [ __ ] that we have
now so and there you know there weren't
as
many people doing it so it was easy to
break records because
you know there just wasn't the pool
wasn't as big now that there are so many
more people there's so much more
technology [ __ ] like that it's getting
harder and harder and harder to
get that little extra there that was
going on in the 30s
that started to come to fruition in the
40s in germany
under under the third reich because the
third reich
wasn't able to [ __ ] pour a bunch of
money into technologies they would pour
money into anything
people think that they were efficient
they weren't they were highly
inefficient they wasted a [ __ ] ton of
money
on crackpot ideas but some of that [ __ ]
actually worked and some of the stuff
would have worked
maybe if they continued to work on it
and one of them was an aircraft
called the sanger and antipodal bomber
and they were going to launch it out off
of a [ __ ] launch rail
in france and george s patton captured
it
and he wrote about it but he even in his
day before he died he didn't know what
it was they
uh he never got an explanation for it
but what it was is it was a giant
concrete launch rail
that you could launch a space plane off
of
the germans were making a space plane
and it was a two-stage thing like a
space shuttle
and you're just to get it up the upper
atmosphere it would bounce off the
atmosphere go to the other side of the
planet
uh go over new york and they were going
to drop a dirty bomb on new york
which was a bunch of cilla silicate
radioactive silicate
and it would come down and contaminate
new york and supposedly get us out of
the war
and anything would skip back across the
atmosphere it would never come into the
atmosphere until it got back over
germany and then they'd
landed and they were working on that
ship
in the 40s it may have worked maybe
some people say the math wasn't quite
right but they would have tried
michael schaefer asked about the flying
bell
the flying bell you have to be more uh
uh specific i don't know if he's talking
about
the nazi bell well yeah as he's talking
about well because you were talking
about
i don't think it actually existed i i
think it was a
all right damn we're getting off topic
dude that's a good question
what was described evidently
it was i think it was a czechoslovakian
guy wrote a book about it and he claims
that an ss one of the ss uberstrom
fuhrer one of these guys who's in charge
of a [ __ ]
special ss project that they were
working on something that was electric
powered
down inside a cave it was shaped like a
bell that had a damn glass window in it
with some kind of purple glowing fluid
that spun around
and it killed all the plants and it
killed a bunch of people working on it
um then they come and say well were they
trying to bend time
were they trying to build some kind of
this and that
the only thing that i know of that blood
glows purple
from with liquid liquid metal in it that
could kill you would be an ion engine
an ion engine would do that and it would
require a lot of power
maybe they were trying to work with ion
propulsion but ion propulsion never
produces the amount of thrust you need
to
[ __ ] drive you can even push the
engine
i mean it's like a slight breeze it's
good in space
maybe to move a satellite but not in an
atmosphere but the germans maybe didn't
know that
maybe they were working on some kind of
ion engine that's the only thing
yeah it's possible right maybe they
thought that that would be an engine
that didn't have hardly any moving parts
you know yeah but it would require an
amazing amount of electricity and would
produce a very small amount of thrust
maybe it was just a research platform to
see
how much thrust you could get maybe
that's what it was
and they wouldn't know much probably
about radiation or
you know ionized particles and stuff you
know that could be very poisonous very
dangerous to you
so maybe they ionized themselves oopsie
but i leaned more towards it that it
didn't happen
i think somebody made up a story that
they worked on an ion engine
you know what i mean yeah like in
retrospect in retrospect somebody knew
what an ion engine would be like and
tried to make up a story about a crude
ion engine
that's probably more likely dgmaniac
says the flying dan bell
[Laughter]
that gave me a really really funny like
mental picture yeah
then xanada said yeah don't forget about
uh maria orsic and the verl society
we did a show about that a long time ago
didn't we yeah i feel like that was in
man that was when we first started the
show i think that might have been like
in one of our first 20 episodes
no need for me to says the fokker v22
um had 200 horsepower i was
uh but what about what about the uh what
was the other one
i think that was the later model what
was it
the folker d4 i think was was the world
war one
most common one i think maybe it had 200
but still 200 horsepower that's a
motorcycle engine
a yamaha r1 makes about 187 horsepower
that's a motorcycle engine still so
today you could just [ __ ]
you and and and an r1 motor weighs
[ __ ] nothing
you know so you can make all the kind of
power out of a
real lightweight motor now you know
[ __ ]
sub 400 pound motorcycle go ahead
all right so where was i all right so
from very very close to the beginning
still yes
so as i said amelia earhart gets like
super jacked about flying and that's all
she wants to do right so january 1921
she actually started taking flying
lessons she found actually a
woman a flight instructor named nita
snook and
she took a job at a at the los angeles
telephone company
as a filing clerk to pay for the lessons
and then she saved up enough money and
bought her first airplane
uh which was a kenner airster and it was
yellow so she called it
the canary now she ended up passing her
flight test in december of 1921
and got her national aeronautics
association license
and then two days later participated her
first flight exhibition
because like i said this was in an era
where
women didn't really fly planes i mean it
wasn't really
a thing so the fact that she was out
there flying planes
was kind of a big deal so everyone would
kind of want to see so she would like
you know go to all the exhibitions and
whatnot
now you know some other [ __ ] happened in
there obviously but 1932
amelia earhart became the first woman
and only the second person
charles lindbergh was the first one who
to fly solo
across the atlantic ocean she flew from
newfoundland canada
uh in a red lockheed vega 5b
and it took her about a day and she went
over the atlantic ocean she was
initially supposed to
land in london england but uh storm blew
her about 400 miles off course
so she ended up uh landing in a field
near
londonderry northern ireland but she
flew across the [ __ ] atlantic she
made it
and um everybody like it was a massive
massive deal it was in all the papers
there was like all these people there
like to see when she landed like i said
this was a huge huge deal
so she comes back to the us and gets the
distinguished flying cross
uh which is the you know the decoration
awarded for heroism or extraordinary
achievement while participating in
aerial flight she's the first woman ever
to get that
uh later that same year which was uh
1932
she made the first solo non-stop flight
across the united states
by a woman now like i said this is the
same flight that this woman on this new
uh naked science documentary
uh you know reenacted in the same plane
like i said
um and was talking about like what a
[ __ ] it was i don't remember how long i
think it took uh
amelia earhart it took her 19 hours to
fly across
the united states to fly
solo from hawaii to the us mainland and
that was in 1935.
she was also real big on
promoting other women in aviation
she formed this uh organization called
the 99s
which uh was an international
organization for the advancement of
female
pilots and uh she was the first
president of it
uh and i guess that is still around
today okay hold on what's that all right
i'm going to answer your question
the fokker dr-1 which that was the
tri-plane
had 110 horsepower the poker dr-7 which
was the one that was better which is
liquid cooled
in the inline it had 160 horsepower
so most of them were that was the best
[ __ ] they had going really the dr7
or the dr7 supposed to be one of the
best planes of the war so 160 horsepower
my motorcycle is only 103. there's a lot
of 160 horsepower
motorcycles running around and i
guarantee that motorcycle engines
we can make today like one-third the
weight you know so you're not talking a
lot of power really okay
yeah now what i was saying before about
amelia earhart being like real ahead of
her time
like so listen to this [ __ ] so they're
talking about a little bit about her
personal life
now she was uh engaged a little while to
this dude named samuel chapman who was a
chemical engineer but then she broke up
with him
and then she starts dating a dude named
george
putnam uh who they called gp he was a
publisher
now he actually pursued her i guess he
was like super ender he proposed her
like a whole bunch of times and she kept
saying no
but then finally she agreed to however
she had a bunch of conditions man um
when they got married she said the the
marriage has to be a partnership
with dual control she did not want any
man telling her what to do
and it actually did end up like pretty
good because he was in publishing
and he seemed like managed her
pr like her public image um helped her
raise money
for her um you know for her flights he
would do [ __ ] like that like he was he
was her backer
but another thing too on the day of the
wedding
amelia earhart wrote him a letter that
said
i want you to understand i shall not
hold you to any medieval code of
faithfulness to me
nor shall i consider myself bound to you
similarly that's right it was an open
relationship i may have to keep some
place where i can go to be by myself now
and then
for i cannot guarantee to endure at all
times the confinement of even an
attractive cage
there you go she saw marriage as a trap
or a cage
um but he seemed like okay with it he
was like all right
that's cool so like i said they seemed
almost like
um you know he clearly was very fond of
her and she was very fond of him but
they
they had a really good like business
relationship too because like i said he
was
he was a publisher so he helped her a
lot with her pr
and like um you know raising like
fundraising for her uh
you know for her flights and whatnot
they were secure in their relationship
i guess so yeah it's really funny too
because i guess
um yeah and her thing was that she
thought
she didn't like the whole thing where
you know the dude was making all the
money and then the woman just stayed at
home she's like no
you know i should make my own money so
you know she was very into like equality
and so like i said this she's very ahead
of her time
um she did not want to be called mrs
putnam uh she didn't
and sometimes the papers would call her
that and it would kind of piss her off
um she she kind of joked that they
should actually call her
husband mr earhart which i thought was
really funny i don't know if they ever
did but i thought that was pretty funny
but yeah so um they never had any kids
or anything although he had a couple
kids
from a previous marriage so i just
thought that was kind of funny so i
thought i'd mention it
now okay so as i said she had done
several fights flights uh previously
she'd gone across the u.s she'd gone
across the atlantic she gone from hawaii
to the u.s whatever
now at this point she wants to do
what charles lindbergh had done she
wants to circumnavigate the globe but
she wants to do it in a little bit of
different ways she wants to do it
um around the equator which hadn't been
done
so okay so there there were actually i
don't know if people know this but they
actually made two attempts at this the
first one they uh
was kind of [ __ ] up so the first one
kind of happened uh
march 17th 1937. so amelia earhart
and her crew they just they flew the
first leg which was from oakland
california
to honolulu right now it was uh amelia
earhart her
navigator fred noonan who would also
accompany her on the
fateful later flight and then
two other dudes who um were technical
advisors and [ __ ] like that because the
thing about amelia earhart
and fred noonan it's like she was a she
was a good pilot fred noonan was an
awesome
navigator but they weren't real
savvy with morse code neither of them
knew morse code
and uh they weren't real savvy with
radios i mean radios
in airplanes was a pretty new thing
so some airplane pilots weren't real
up on the new technology was huge back
then it weighed a lot
yeah and so bigger than an old-fashioned
television
yeah so um so neither of them were real
savvy with the radio so they needed like
some people to come along with
uh with them to kind of help out in that
regard
however during the first leg because
like i said this is
this was their first attempt at like
going around the world but they were
only on the first leg of the journey
uh but they had some problems with uh
the propeller hubs variable pitch
mechanisms
and they had to land in hawaii for the
plane to get looked at
um so this plane which was an electra
uh they took it to luke field uh which
was
navy that was on ford island in pearl
harbor and
it had to stay there for three days for
repairs and then
um it took off again now
this there was three people on board it
was amelia and fred and uh harry manning
like the other dude
[ __ ] off so the next place they were
gonna fly they were gonna fly from uh
pearl harbor
like luke field and pearl harbor they
were gonna fly to howland island
which is this little like [ __ ] tiny
island in the pacific ocean
now harry manning was the only guy that
knew how was the only one that knew how
to operate the radio properly
um now he was supposed to use like
the radio direction finding to find the
island because like i said the pacific
ocean is big y'all and this island is
really really small um so he was gonna
do that but
the flight never ended up leaving
because when they went to take off
there was uh what they call an
uncontrolled ground loop
the forward landing gear collapsed both
propellers hit the ground
and then the plane skidded on the on its
belly and a portion of the runway was
damaged
now even to this day people still talk
about what the [ __ ] was the deal with
the plane because i think a lot of
people are like oh let's blame the pilot
like because amelia earhart oh she's a
woman haha they can't drive or anything
but several witnesses and that's what
manning said
but a bunch of witnesses that were
watching the plane to take off said that
one of the tires
blew um or the it looked like one of the
tires blew or that the landing gear had
collapsed that that's what happened
so i don't know if it was pilot error or
if it was mechanical error
but regardless um you know they
they didn't make it so they said okay
well we gotta scrap this [ __ ] and
we'll try it again some other time so
you know they just said forget it they
took the plane and they took it to
uh the facility for repairs now
um so harry manning who was their radio
operator
he kind of came out and like i said he
kind of blamed
amelia for the plane getting [ __ ] up
even though as i said it might have been
a blown tire or collapsed
landing gear we don't really know
because you know there are differing
witness accounts but he decided that he
wasn't going to he's like well i don't
really trust her
to pilot a plane around the world so i'm
not doing this
so um so at this point there's only two
of them so it's only amelia
and fred noonan the navigator and as i
said neither one of them
were super skilled with uh the whole
radio thing
which may have contributed i don't know
though
i i don't know if if them not being
skilled radio operators really had
all that much to do with what happened
to them i have some other
theories about it but you know we'll see
i don't know i'm just you know
i'm just saying so they scrapped it then
later on okay so june 1st 1937
amelia uh they're gonna do this [ __ ]
again they've been planning it all this
time
so her and fred noonan take off from
oakland california going east
this is going to be the second attempt
she's going to be the first
woman pilot to circumnavigate the globe
like i said around
the equator now her plane was a twin
engine
lockheed 10e electra and so
they go to miami first then to south
america
then they cross the atlantic to africa
then to india and southeast asia so like
i said they made it
a long way they made it almost all the
way around right
they're in there hypothesized and then
maybe
amelia earhart was a lesbian no i don't
think so
no i don't think she was either um the
way she looked
and she's wearing pants and the short
hair and everything that was real
popular in the 20s and 30s
there was a whole subculture of new
uh women that were like that kind of
coming out of the damn flapper scene
she was some somebody kind of like um
louise brooks it was a lot and they were
tended to be rich girls
rich girls who uh did whatever did
whatever the [ __ ] they wanted to do
and the idea was that they were real
competent
and they they they could have sex with
whoever they wanted to
yeah and they were coming from a place
where it's like well if a man can do it
i can't i can do it too
yeah yeah they smoked cigarettes yeah
which they weren't really supposed to do
they wore pants which they weren't
really supposed to do and they had short
hair
hell i remember my grandmother um when
she was young she was scandalized by
women wearing pants yeah and that was
like you know now somebody's 30s now
some of them like louise
you know she was young she did mess
around with uh
uh lesbians and stuff when she was in
germany but she
didn't consider herself to be a lesbian
yes would have sex with a lesbian
it's just one like yeah yeah i got that
[ __ ] and then just move on and then
just go do some dudes
yeah i don't really think and honestly
amelia earhart i
as much as she had i don't think that
she was
averse to men in general or marriage in
general
she just i don't know i just think she
didn't like
she didn't like being constrained she
didn't like
you know the the kind of overarching
[ __ ] at the time
you know you have to understand who
american men were in this era
okay they were dudes a lot like the
chinese men of today
they're real close to that real real
cut and dried kind of boring real
family oriented super super i don't want
to say uptight yeah but kind of uptight
and traditional real real
well uptight and they kind of expected
you know a certain way
i go to my office for you know seven
eight hours a day when i come home you
must have the house clean you must have
dinner cooked for me you must do this
you must do everything's all for
children you must raise all my children
you must do my secretarial work you must
do and i'm gonna go out and i'm gonna do
work and if i come in late don't ask
where i
where i've been yeah it was very much
like that
and that's you know and because you know
this is a man's world
not like they're like that you know what
i mean yeah and uh
that still exists in china right now and
you know and and i don't think it's as
bad in japan as it used to be but korea
is a little bit like that
you know certain other countries other
cultures are like that just real
the man is in charge type of deal but
then when you look at the dude
he only weighs like 140 pounds and
little skinny guys you know
that it's just
go look at the go look at those dudes
back in those days they were [ __ ]
skinny
real skinny and um
just i they were dragged i'm gonna tell
you they were a drag well yeah i can
just see recordings of those dudes and
just go nah
well you imagine being like married to
that and like having it because like you
imagine how much more of a drag that
would be
well like i said the thing that's cool
the thing that i was thought was cool
about amelia earhart
was that she had these really like for
the time very very liberal attitudes but
she didn't make a big i mean she didn't
she made a big deal about it but not in
a way that she was kind of she wasn't
self-conscious about it she was just
kind of like this is
how i am just like deal with it but not
in an arrogant
way i mean because she was actually
really humble and kind of soft-spoken
and stuff and it wasn't real
she didn't like being in the spotlight
or anything she was just like you know
yeah the only p
the only people back in this era who
weren't really drags
were celebrities real famous people are
super super rich people
but then you've you can even study and
read a book about say like howard hughes
howard hughes was the head of the
competition for his time
but if you read the fine print he was
kind of a drag too
you know he wouldn't be able to compete
against a cool um a cool modern
guy of today you know i mean like his
version of [ __ ] get wild be going
down on some girl
oh man i went down you know what i mean
he would actually write down the dates
that's literal
yeah write down the dates um yeah on the
douches
because he douche them out first it was
a ritual
we talked about that he thought he was
going to the moon when he was doing it
so you're not talking about the same
mentality all right at all
i'm glad that shit's gone well it's not
completely gone there's still some dudes
that have that mentality but i'm just
like glad
i'm glad i'm not that i didn't live back
then yeah that's all i'm saying it'd be
boring
it would be awful yeah and then you had
dudes that were straight-up predators
that didn't know that should have known
better
guys like that was all errol flynn he
bought a 13 year old girl from the damn
parents
kept her in his house he had a special
room with an overhead
two-way mirror so other people he could
bring his friends over
and they could all watch each other
[ __ ] this girl that was some weird
[ __ ]
then he'd give him cocaine yeah and then
he'd go
he was big into these underage girls he
was a hollywood star this is way back in
the day harold flint
not a good dude no a lot of them weren't
yeah not a good dude at all but the
thing is is that
they didn't society didn't have a
[ __ ]
concept that things like that would
happen so every now and then you'd get a
dude that would just try to take
advantage of the [ __ ]
like i would never suspect that i'm
doing this 13 year old girl
they you know they're they're you know
they didn't think that i guess they
thought people didn't think or maybe
maybe it could have been you could get
married at 13 in a lot of the states at
that time everyone was like
well yeah that's old enough close enough
yeah
weird it is weird this weird [ __ ] well
yeah like nowadays you should be in
prison for that you'd be pretty
brightly so yeah but well the thing
about it back then
because people were talking about it it
was probably less sketchy back then
yeah but yeah right the thing oh and i
forgot to mention too because i think
somebody was talking about in the chat
about um
how it's easier to be like you know like
somebody like amelia earhart when you
have money
she actually didn't um her family was
not wealthy
really um and the thing about it was
that all the flights that she did
um they cost a lot of money so she had
to
fundraise her and her husband like i
said he was very he was instrumental in
kind of like helping her out with her
public relations
because he was a publisher and they had
to raise money
for her uh circumnavigating the globe
flight
she was basically on like a publicity
tour for like a year before that
going around raising money like doing
exhibitions
doing all this other kind of stuff she
wrote books and [ __ ] like that too
so she was trying to raise money for it
and some people have speculated that it
might have been
a contributing factor to you know why
she
you know supposedly crashed or
disappeared or whatever was that she
might have been
exhausted from the [ __ ] because she
had not
rested for like a year prior to that she
had been touring around
fundraising for the around-the-world uh
trip that she was doing so they
absolutely did not have
you know [ __ ] you money where they could
just kind of like oh we decided
as a lark we're gonna like fly around
the world they had to raise the money
for that
and that's what she did she went on a
publicity tour and raised money
and you know and she was [ __ ] worn
out and you know some people that knew
her i was watching some documentaries
about it and so people that like knew
her and they were talking about she was
absolutely
like really really worn out like when
she went
when she took off on that but she was
just so determined that she wanted to be
the first woman to do it
that they couldn't really talk her out
of it so you know
so i don't know if that contributed or
not but it possibly it possibly could
another thing i want to add too it's
interesting some
documentaries mention this some other
ones not so much
but fred noonan her navigator
um i'm not blaming the dude or anything
like that okay so
according to everyone i have you know
read or seen
he was a brilliant navigator he had
worked for pan am
and you know various other things
however
he had been fired from pan am and he'd
been fired from pan
am because essentially he was
a drunk now
it may be that the night before
the fatal accident or disappearance or
whatever
i think that he and amelia had an
argument
uh because she reported on the radio
that she was having some like i think
she said something like personnel
problems or something like that
and i guess he had got mad at her and
like got off to a bar and like got
[ __ ] up
so that also might have contributed i'm
just saying
it's you know what i mean so i it's
interesting because i saw some
documentaries that mentioned
that he was kind of known as a drunk and
that's what he got fired from pan am for
and other documentaries that didn't
mention it so
i just thought i'd mention it i'm just
saying um but he did get fired for that
so it's not like i'm just pulling it out
my ass
so um yeah so they went to miami like i
said south america
then they flew across the atlantic to
africa then east to india southeast asia
now on june 29th 1937
they got to lay or lie new guinea
now when they touched down here they had
already gone
22 000 miles and they only had
7 000 miles to go this was like i said
this was pretty much the last leg of
their journey they had one more like
stop for gas and then it was
then they were gonna uh you know a
couple more software gas and that they
were going to be done
so they landed in new guinea and then
they
uh took off on july 2nd
for howland island like i said that was
where they had you know been going to
before
and that's where they were going to
refuel refuel next time
however this was when
they both disappeared now
it's creepy because there is actually
video
it's very brief but somebody took some
video
of them getting into the plane like you
know and like
you know climbing up side of the plane
and then like leaving
um you know leaving for howland island
and that's like the last time that they
were ever seen so watching that footage
is like really super creepy like i saw
it on a
on a documentary earlier and i was like
like i got goosebumps watching it
so what ended up happening so they're
flying toward howland island and
some at some point during that time they
pretty much disappeared now
they did have radio contact with her
because like i said
amelia earhart was so famous it was
her [ __ ] was in all the papers like all
this uh the circumnavigation that she
was doing
and so there were ships and stuff like
at
all the points where she was gonna land
to
make radio contact with her and like
check and make sure she was all right
like so she had [ __ ] around the world
it was you know it was a plotted course
so
they had ships and [ __ ] there to you
know check up on her
right so they do have
some radio transmissions from her
um you know that occurred shortly before
her
disappearance now what probably ended up
happening
so there was um a u.s coast guard
u.s coast guard cutter and it was
anchored off of howland island and they
were waiting for her
like to get the radio signal they were
getting radio signals from her
so for a while it was kind of like
um they heard she was reporting like you
know i'm going 140 knots or whatever
everything's okay that's what she always
said at the end everything okay that's
what she would say
but then apparently what ended up
happening
because a lot of people have said that
it's like well
she would she should have had enough
fuel to go because when she vanished she
should have had two more hours of fuel
so it's like she should have
had enough fuel to like get to another
you know set of islands or whatever
but i think what ended up happening is
that
what from the documentary i was watching
earlier which is pretty new
they said she did have technically she
did have enough fuel for that
but one uh there had been a bad storm
like over her route and she had to fly
over it which like i said uses more
fuel um also the headwind was twice as
strong
as what uh they had which slows you down
which means you burn about 10 20 more uh
fuel so it's possible that she could
have run out of gas
and it really does seem like that might
be what happened because her last
transmission
she sounded kind of panicked and she was
saying that she like had run out of gas
and she was saying something like you
know
i don't see the island like where are
you and so it might have been that
they kind of got turned around a little
bit you know what i mean um because i
think what happened
at least according to these guys that
were doing this documentary um
that had sort of plotted all this [ __ ]
out on computers and everything
they said they think what happened was
that fred noonan like they knew where
they were
but they were running out of gas and
then you know they weren't quite sure
like where the island was because the
island's really small
and it's like so he started doing like
what they call like a ladder searching
like he was kind of going like that like
looking for the island
and they said now if they had kept doing
that then they would have gone right to
the island
so they must have run out of gas because
they said that's pretty much
what the last uh you know what the last
transmission said that they were running
out of
fuel it's the most likely thing that i
think it's the most likely though
do you know what i'm i'm not saying that
that's what happened they're just saying
that
what what she was doing was extremely
dangerous
you take it but yeah you take it for
granted that you can fly across the
ocean
that's because you're in these gigantic
[ __ ] jet planes that are fully
equipped with really high-tech [ __ ]
that fly when pressurized cabins way
above the weather
okay that's not what she's in she's in a
[ __ ] powered kite
all right without any trying to fly
basically blind over the ocean you're
basically blind
because there's no ground no no terrain
features
so she had a map and a compass yeah
that's
it so that means you're flying by
instruments you might as well just be
blind
because you can't find your location by
looking down and trying to do terrain
features association
is nothing but waves so
wind conditions and everything you know
burned upper fuel
probably hard to tell for sure you are
where you are you might
you start to question yourself did i
actually doze off for a little while
maybe i forgot lost track of time maybe
maybe i was off course for a while and
didn't realize it
you know just a few degrees over a few
just a few degrees off
course over time consent you go
hundreds of miles away yeah and that's
what that's what might have happened i
mean because like i said there was a
storm
and apparently she tried to fly above it
yeah um
but she still could have been blown just
a couple miles off course and then the
farther she went the more of course she
got
imagine you're trying you're being
buffeted around and you're trying to
maintain course you're just looking at
it down
artificial horizon and a compass trying
to i guess i'm going the right way it's
in this way
somewhere like i said like people that
flew planes like around the world back
then giant brass balls
yeah i mean what you're doing is not
safe
right it's very nature it's amazing and
she knew that i mean i guess
the fact that she made it 22 000 miles
though in this plane
that's why everybody was paying
attention to it that's why it was a feat
because you had a good chance of getting
killed that's what happened to her
well yeah that's what happened to her
unless you believe that she like turned
up several i don't know well later there
was some stuff that turned up that maybe
they made it to an island
they may have but yeah i don't know i
don't know
so yeah they found some stuff supposedly
they found some of her belongings on a
little island
yeah yeah i don't know if that got
verified
yeah that's the thing it's like i keep
seeing that they found like a jar of
freckle cream
and like a shoe i think the shoe and a
piece of paper
or a book or something and this [ __ ] the
one shoe that they found i'm pretty sure
that that wasn't hers because even
though it was a brand that she wore i
think it was like too big for her
i think they did find some bones but i
don't know if they know exactly if
that's because they said well it might
be
it was from that time yeah it was from
around that time period yeah
but so after uh they disappeared
so uh franklin d roosevelt was the
president at that time
so they searched for uh amelia and fred
for like two weeks
all over the place but they never found
anything no sign of wreckage no
nothing so july 19th 1937 they are
declared
lost at sea so as i said there have been
a lot of
uh interesting theories about this
uh honestly i probably think it's the
most likely that she simply
you know got a little bit off course and
then by the time they were
coming into howland island like i said
they seemed like they were
kind of figuring out where it was but
they didn't have enough fuel to get
there and they probably just ditched it
into the ocean
um but maybe not it's it could be
that um they kept on going and made it
to another island
but maybe just died before they were
rescued
that could be as well now as i said
they've been looking
for her and for her plane for
you know since [ __ ] 1937 however long
ago that was
it was a long time i can't math where
she probably went down was in the drink
yeah i mean like i said where they found
those things on that little island and
it's just the islands like a damn sand
bar in the middle of the yeah we're
talking about islands these are tiny
little
yeah little bitty i mean at least like
finding that in the middle of the
pacific ocean with no gps
or anything there's like a sand boat i
mean in the middle of the ocean
the top of some mountain that used to be
there i guess anyway
um there was some stuff on it but i
don't remember if it was
i do remember that that that that was in
a location where she was
hundreds of miles away where she should
have been
which is yeah i think it was three or
four hundred miles yeah
possible but unlikely depends on the
weather conditions well the plan was
if they had a plan that if they didn't
make howland island
then there was another set of islands
like 300 miles and they were supposed to
head for that
so it's possible they could have made it
there although i suspect that they might
have run out of
if they didn't run out of fuel then they
should have been able to make it because
they had another two hours worth of fuel
technically if they didn't have all the
problems with the storms and the
headwind and stuff so it's possible they
could have had enough fuel to get there
it's not impossible that they could have
made it to that other island but if they
did make it to that other island i
think they died before they got rescued
the plane wasn't there
yeah they never did find the plane yeah
which i don't know she maybe she that
island was pretty small you probably
couldn't land on the island
maybe that's why maybe she just ditches
water and they swam
to it yeah i mean but they didn't find
the plane around that island though but
that could have been maybe taken away by
currents over time
difficult to say i mean they've been
there they've done [ __ ]
sonar they've had like the [ __ ] deep
sea robots they've had all that [ __ ]
like around
that area and they still haven't found
anything they won't find that plane i
don't know i mean that's the thing
it's it's people can say yes it's been
you know yes it's been like decades and
decades but it's like it's kind of like
look how long it took them to find the
titanic for [ __ ] sake
and that's like a gigantic cruise ship
yeah her plane was just like a dinky ass
little two-person plane yeah and it
in the pacific ocean yeah and it's salt
water it would have just eaten it up
there wouldn't be anything left a motor
maybe yeah
see so there's one group um
i saw that they're called the
international group for historic
aircraft recovery
now they think that um amelia earhart
and fred noonan probably
went off course from howland island like
we said um because like i said there'd
been some bad weather
and that they landed 350 miles to the
southwest on gardner island like i said
it's not called that anymore it's now
called nikumaroro
um but that was like i said that was
their backup plan
so they you know it wasn't like out of
the blue it was they knew
where the other island was like if they
[ __ ] up the ship to the other one
um so they did suspect that maybe okay
maybe they landed on
the formerly known gardner island so
they sent the navy planes to fly over
there
and they said that i don't think that
island was inhabited at the time but
they did see some [ __ ] on there that
looked like maybe somebody had been on
there
um but they kind of like checked it out
but they didn't see the plane
um so i guess they didn't really find
like a lot of [ __ ]
but they suspect um
as we were saying that they probably
made it to gardner island
but that they were there for a few days
or a few weeks and probably just died
there like before the rescuers were able
to come
stop propaganda says they still can't
find modern airliners so what
what are the odds they can find that
little that's what i'm saying it's like
yes i know a lot of people looked i know
a lot of people you know
now they have sonar they have all you
know they have all this other stuff now
but it's kind of like that plane is
really
small and the pacific ocean is very very
big domino bomb says that uh that
airplane is like dust in the wind
now yeah that airplane's gone
yeah see so they did find some [ __ ] on
on gardner island
they found like a piece of plexiglass
that
possibly could have come from the
airplane window maybe it was the same
kind of plexiglass they used in that
window
um they found like i said it was like a
little empty jar of uh
looked like freckle cream which was
something that amelia earhart used
they found some bones that might have
been a finger
like i said they found a shoe but i'm
not sure if they found out if that was
hers or not because it was like
not her size um so
in 2017 this group like sent an
expedition
to that island like like i said it's now
called nicomero
and they had some uh some cadaver dogs
and they were sniffing around there but
they they were looking for uh more
skeletal remains but they didn't uh find
anything they didn't find any bones they
didn't find any dna or anything like
that
but the fact that they did find you know
some plexiglass some little cosmetic
thing
could have been hers because like i said
nobody lived on that island at that time
so it's possible that they ditched the
plane in the ocean and swam to that
island
but nobody rescued them because nobody
lived there you know what i mean
so as i said so here's some of the
theories
about what happened uh most likely
theories first
amelia earhart ran out of fuel crashed
and perished in the pacific ocean
as i said either this or the gardner
island one i'm kind of
leaning more toward those uh because i
kind of feel like she either ran out of
fuel
because as i said her last radio
transmission was very panicked
and she said she was low on fuel and
if they they don't know exactly where
she was when they got that radio
transmission
but they were trying to like triangulate
where it might have been and they said
if it's where
we think it was she wouldn't have made
it right like so that she
she would have run out of fuel before
that so she probably would have crashed
into the ocean
um so probably and like i said you know
they if you crash in that part of the
pacific ocean they probably never
find you even though they know the
general area where to look but it's a
giant [ __ ]
place and it's like super deep there too
and the airplane flies underwater too
i don't realize it yeah that's true if
it sinks right it starts to sink
and the water acts on the wings just
like it would
wind and it can glide and coast
underneath the water
it might go for miles before it ever hit
so it hits the bottom of the ocean
so where it hits the drink isn't where
the airplane's going to be it could be
any direction
yeah the boats do the same thing they go
down and then they
take off in some weird direction and
then hit the hit the bottom
yeah i mean yeah i don't know people
like don't
do because not only is the [ __ ]
ocean like vast it's also like really
really deep
yeah and i think where the where they
think she if she
indeed crashed into the ocean i think
that area the ocean was like some
ridiculous
what did they say it was i was like
assuming documentary did i want to say
it was like 17
000 feet deep or some [ __ ] like that it
was like something ridiculous
it was like super super deep but it's
like yeah they're probably never funny i
don't like the ocean too much
i don't either out there in the ocean
you look down you're just down in the
blackness you're like god damn it's like
i'm flying
well yeah you know thousands of feet up
you know what's funny
one of the dudes um in that ball in that
documentary that i was watching
yeah he um this one guy that was like
investigating
and and i think that's where i heard
that it was like 17 000 feet deep or
whatever
um i could be remembering that wrong but
he said i wanted to go
skydiving because i wanted he's like you
know when you're in the water it's like
hard to say it's oh it's 17 000 feet
down but he's like so i wanted to see
what it looked like from the air
because he'd never been yeah so he's
like so he wanted to get an idea of how
far that was a long way and it's a long
way and he's like so
you know with all that water in the way
it's hard to determine
like how long how far it is but it
really gives you some perspective on
what you're doing
you jumped out of a plane you're always
afraid there's some [ __ ] sea monster
underneath there gonna [ __ ] come up
with his mouth and [ __ ] get you boom
see that's what my nightmares are like
that my nightmares are like that i'd be
paddling up there on the [ __ ] top of
the [ __ ] ocean and look down
with your see that jaws poster did not
help me
with your [ __ ] goggles and you look
down like that and then you kind of go
oh i don't want to look down there too
long because you might just see a big
mouth come up out of the darkness
see damn that's like i said i have
nightmares about that
well i i think that's why giants should
grow you remember
we talked about this before but you
remember the um
20 000 leagues under the sea ride the
old one at disney world
yeah or in disneyland they had it there
yeah the octopus and the octopus
the eyeball i i loved that ride because
it was scary because i love scary [ __ ]
but that was like the scariest part of
it for me
because that's what my nightmares were
like i would have nightmares where i was
swimming in like the deepest part of the
ocean and i couldn't see and then all of
a sudden this huge thing
would go by and there'd be like an eye
right there
what was going on oh my god it was a
total illusion you weren't even
underneath the water no you weren't
but when i was little that like scared
the [ __ ] out of me but
but i still wanted to go on it over and
over again because i'm a glutton for
punishment
but um but yeah so as i said
theory one she crashed into the ocean
which
to me that seems like the most likely
just from
hearing like reading her last um
radio transmission she did seem to be
aware
that she was low on fuel and that she
she seemed to like she was trying to
figure out where the island was or where
the ship was
she's asking about what well does she
have her clothes on
no she doesn't have one her clothes are
a collar on the website yeah
that's what i call her she's like no i
want to go in there
you want to go in the closet there you
go oh boy
yeah i don't know why she's so excited
she goes closet and then it gets
disappointed that's nice
she's like this doesn't go outside i
don't know what it's like every single
time she's been in there lots of times i
don't know why she keeps doing that
but yeah so yeah i just i i think that's
probably the most likely scenario she
knew she was running low on fuel
she was desperately looking for the ship
um you know to tell her like where the
[ __ ] am i like where's the island i
thought it was right here
so i don't know i think i think she may
be crashing that we should maybe not
yeah clothes we call her collar clothes
yeah because i gotta put a collar on for
that right well when she goes out on the
back porch i'm like put your clothes on
yeah and she knows too she'll she'll sit
there and go and yeah i'll let you put
the
put the collar on let's put the collar i
don't want people to think that she's a
stray so i'll put
i'll put a collar on her i mean i don't
think the neighbors would steal her but
yeah and the neighbors on either side of
us know her anyway because she sits in
their bushes
but uh yeah so theory number two uh
amelia earhart landed safely on gardner
island like i mentioned before
but died before she could be rescued um
so as i said this this takes into
consideration that maybe she did have
enough fuel
to get to gardner island which like i
said was 350 miles
uh farther from where she was going uh
it's actually it's very small also
uninhabited it's coral atoll
um so it's possible she could have made
it that far and
landed there or ditched the plane in the
ocean and then they swam to the island
um but you know for whatever reason you
know they weren't rescued obviously
uh you know they did find a couple of
artifacts on there that suggested that
maybe they had made it
to this particular island or maybe she
just made it to the island um
but they haven't found any bones or
anything like that
anything definitive uh theory number
three now we're getting into the weirder
[ __ ]
theory number three amelia earhart's
flight was an elaborate scheme to spy on
the japanese
who captured her after she crashed now
i don't know how much stock i want to
put in this because like i said this was
1937 so it's not like it was in the
thick of world war ii you know what i'm
saying i'm not saying that it's crazy
that they wouldn't have sent people to
spy on the japanese
i'm just saying what could she tell well
and the thing about it is like if you're
gonna send somebody to spy on the
japanese it seemed a little weird to do
it like with amelia earhart
like the most famous woman in the world
at the time and everybody knew what she
was doing right
and she wasn't anywhere near japan
anyways what did yeah what is she going
to do fly over
and then fly back and go yeah i saw some
japanese people
what's the point of reconnaissance stuff
where are the targets what did she
no that's not what that was yeah i think
that's just kind of like one of those
things where it's like we want to make
this story more exciting than it
actually is
um that plane was not equipped for any
kind of spy mission well and like
and she wasn't even flying over japan
anyway and like and this was before
world war ii like
like i said this was kind of before that
would have maybe even been a
consideration i feel like
and she doesn't really seem like the
ideal person
to do that because she was famous and
everybody knew what she was doing i mean
every
every leg of her tour was like on the
front page
theorists would say well her fame was
her greatest
i know i know how
he wanted to be an undercover like drug
yeah he was gonna go undercover
like he thought that was gonna work he
genuinely did think it was gonna work i
think
he really didn't seem to think that he
would be going against joe on that
we're gonna do a review on that movie we
did a little tease already
on on uh elvis and nixon
but i think it could i think it's not
real clear
i gotta look through some interview
maybe some old interviews of his friends
who are with him
did was he just trying to get a badge
and talk his way into it did he just
think this was all
real fun i'm gonna go see the president
they're gonna give me a badge i'm gonna
see
yeah it'll be a big lark yeah watch him
i'm gonna get i'm gonna
detective at large i don't know possibly
yeah and then
that would be like a big [ __ ] lark
you know like i got my badge
you know i did it yeah only the king
could do it
you know it might have been something
like that maybe it was like it was like
a bet he had a bed
as friends or with himself i think just
to challenge himself
to do something to do it to do to get a
great prize
something he shouldn't have really had
the damn badge yeah
well he had oh brother badges so you
know he was in the badge game
he wanted the biggest badge of them all
kind of like the girl scouts
you know getting your girl scout badges
got your camping badge
got your cookie selling badge you wanted
to [ __ ] become a federal agent
yeah no need for me too says coconut
crabs
wait a minute [ __ ] coconut crabs might
have got her yeah i just
i just heard that as well those coconut
crabs if you don't know
are giant terrifying creatures yeah
they're big old sand crabs
although i imagine they might be
delicious i mean you know maybe
they're everywhere on those islands they
have them yeah and um
i don't know though because people
aren't eating them or there wouldn't be
that many of them
maybe they don't taste good either that
or just
the natives are just appalled by them
like how could a crab not taste good
look man you got people in china and
thailand that'll eat cockroaches
we would never eat that we got tons of
them they'd be loved they'd love it over
here
eat up them cockroaches no i wish
somebody would eat them yeah but you
know maybe they're like
on those islands maybe those coconut
crabs are like their version of
cockroaches
yeah don't eat that they just crawl in
your house and like [ __ ]
snip off your dog's tail and whatnot you
know people
people in louisiana used to eat [ __ ]
blossom and armadillo
you know but they don't eat that anymore
yeah
that's pretty nasty yeah that's pretty
nice but i think they were just trying
to show off how
how [ __ ] cajun they were by eating it
see i feel like a lot of food that's
really gross i think that's just like
they eat that for a dare
yeah dylan just so they can show
like how you know what i mean it's kind
of like the scots and haggis
yeah it's like i know this is like it's
like i know this is gross it's like
and i think like the fact that other
people being grossed out by it is part
of the appeal
of it maybe i don't know maybe it is
good i don't know
i don't know why you'd want to eat it
well i don't know why you'd want to eat
a possum
they're slow they make good pets
and they're and they're dirty you know
what i mean they spend all their time
they're kind of cute though they're kind
of ugly cute and then you have
armadillos which is the best the closest
thing you're going to get to a maggot
i mean they're just [ __ ] filthy they
carry leprosy and everything
and they just crawl inside a deer's
[ __ ] and you know all that's inside
i saw it i saw it myself that was weird
that was that's one of my favorite
stories of yours well i think i like it
because the first time you told it to me
you even had like all the sound effects
and everything yeah like
of the armadillo like popping out of the
deer's butthole yeah
and like that just it just made me laugh
and laugh
[Laughter]
i was driving i was driving to the deer
camp
outside heidelberg mississippi my dad's
deer camp
i'm driving and came around the bend and
there was a dead deer in the middle of
the street
so i went into the oncoming lane to go
around it
because you know you can see cars coming
for miles so there's nobody coming
i went to the oncoming lane like that
and as i was changing lanes that
[ __ ] deer moved and you thought it
was a zombie deer i was like whoa
and it went and that [ __ ] that
that [ __ ] armadillo popped right out
of its ass i was like what the [ __ ] in
the [ __ ]
of all the things to see that armadillo
popped out of that
popped out of that yummy and was running
out running out of there
looking over his shoulder at me yeah i
got something is that the
all-you-can-eat buffet
because it's soft in there they don't
have real sharp teeth but
he went inside the ass to eat some eat
some soft stuff
and then got full and came back out
[ __ ] hilarious i didn't ever seen
that before i was like what the [ __ ]
i've still never seen that yeah that
really i'd have to pull over to like
recover from this
i was appalled i don't know if i'd be
appalled i think i would just
like i said i think i would just like
practice well when the deer move
that you know what i mean what you know
i thought yeah oh my god it's a zombie
apocalypse and it popped out of him
i've seen this movie ran away looking at
me over his shoulder
what movie was that where the first
thing was like a was like a was it a
deer or a sheep that like woke up
i don't know i think was it 28 days
later i kind of feel like it was a
british zombie movie
i wanted oh men i wanted to mention too
that when i was on my hike this morning
i saw two big does run across the path
and usually like sometimes i see them
when it's like real early morning i'm
like it was early morning but
i sometimes see them when there's not a
lot of people around
but this morning there was tons of
people there's people out jogging
walking their dogs riding bikes whatever
and these two deer were just kind of
like oh [ __ ] and they were just like
running across from someone's backyard
like up into some
yeah like a property that's for sale up
there they haven't developed yet
so i was kind of like well hey you guys
um but yeah so
the whole thing about amelia earhart
being a spy
you know spying on the japanese i think
that came from a movie
that came out later yeah like there was
a few a few years later
in the 40s there was a movie called
flight for freedom that was about her
and it kind of like you know put that
spy angle in there like i said they were
trying to make a more exciting movie so
i kind of feel like maybe that's where
that theory came from
it was like a movie rosalind russell was
in it was she was she was the other one
with the boobs
i don't know no that was jane russell
that was jane russell with the boobs
jane russell i gotta i can go
go back through boobapedia animals
wait a minute it's the internet so that
probably already exists but if it
doesn't exist
yeah you need to start it yeah
booboopedia that list of all
right there is your calling yeah it's
bubology
that's your calling boob study yeah
doctor of bibology
yeah you could do it yeah yeah yeah do a
class on boob study yeah
you know what that might be an
interesting class and i'm not i'm not
bullshitting that might be an
interesting
class the perception of breasts
throughout like
throughout art history like [ __ ] like
that that that would be fascinating
tom's study of the booba sphere the boob
is fair
i mean that would be really interesting
i think it'd be interesting
yeah and i had to come up with all kinds
of terms for like
features on boobs whether they're kind
of like high slung or low slung
[ __ ] you know what i mean that's like
they're broad or pointed they had to
come up with terminology
yeah like are the areolas like yeah big
relationships yeah we're talking about
dinner
dinner plate size
what are we talking about here you know
that way that way
real men can sit and discuss the [ __ ]
booboology in an intelligent fashion we
can actually have terminology for it
that's what i mean there's a science
behind it yeah
i will i i legit think that would be an
interesting i think it would be an
interesting class
yeah i'd have to study the works that
have come before me first
well yeah everybody else has a system
and you know
i'm sure somebody somebody may have a
system you know how humans are yeah you
have to credit that system first
as like your forebearers and then you
build upon that
sure and correct any you correct any
mistakes
in in the theory of that man's boobology
you know what i mean
because there might be mistakes in it
all science is built upon
the shoulders of giants well yeah didn't
i i think isaac newton said that
yeah but um what did wasn't it he knew
boobs
one of these days you know what i was
just speaking of isaac newton i don't
know why but it's like isaac newton
used to work at the mint and he was like
real up on like trying to get people for
forgery and [ __ ] like yeah he didn't
catch people for forgery
yeah and it was i read a whole book
about it and it was fascinating
like i said this is what i think i
mentioned this before but i'm really
into
non-fiction books that talk about the
history of [ __ ] that you never thought
about the history of yeah i just love
that little niche history [ __ ] like that
it's funny and i read a whole book about
his uh his career at the mint and it was
like it sounds boring but it really
really wasn't it was fascinating what is
funny though is that modern scientists
[ __ ] hold this guy in hard regard as
if he was the father of logic and reason
but he was
he was very religious he was trying to
[ __ ] find well yeah he was
he was an insufferable [ __ ] say
evidently he was
yeah well it couldn't stand to be around
i don't know well scientists that would
they
they um appreciate him for his
contributions obviously which were huge
but people are complicated
yeah and i think that a lot of um
because the book that i read about him
was by a scientist and there's like you
know
rightly so he is considered like you
know one of the father
fathers of modern science but he had
some real stupid ideas like he really
believed in alchemy like he believed in
all that [ __ ]
well that was their version of chemistry
at the time but it was it had so much
spiritism involved in it
but for me as a man the telltale sign
of [ __ ] weakness is that thank you dc
what do you say continued catch-up for
years of freeloading and taboo bology oh
thank you
enjoy it enjoy the tennis sphere i like
that better than booboo's favorite thing
too
sounds better the the telling feature of
[ __ ] isaac newton was that he had no
way with women and probably died of
virgin
so yeah i i think he might have as well
he was a little weird yeah so yeah okay
bro
he was a weirdo have fun with it dude
so you know he was an interesting
character though i found him a very
interesting character
now some people might say well he was
gay i don't think so i think
no i didn't get that i don't think so
the thank you i think the dude probably
had what you would call asperger's or
syndrome or some something oh yeah yeah
some something on the scale of autism
today it was like neurodynamics
they just said that he just was
inseparable that you really just
couldn't be around him but he
he did provide a lot of results i mean
you know i mean he came up with
fantastic results
and that sounds like somebody with on on
the autism
and he was really really focused on his
work man that's like that's kind of all
he was interested in right which like i
said that
might have been the only thing to him
though that kind of like tracks but as i
said he was a genius
in that way but other ways if you've got
enough time you can become a genius if
you focus on something very narrow
i mean and he just concentrated
everything on these just
on these little subjects although i
would say that probably
um him trying to catch four drawers
is probably the [ __ ] the most
sophisticated thing he probably did
actually
and like i said if it's like i can't
remember the name of that book right now
like i'd have to look it up because i
read it like probably several years ago
but it was just it was about that whole
time period in his life and it's
really really interesting yeah all right
he was great at trying
it he was he was really good at it he's
supposed to be really good at
[ __ ] interrogation yeah so
you didn't want to be interrogated by
him no he'd [ __ ] catch you in
something
so he saw you as a machine because he
was a machine
he knew about deductive reasoning and
stuff he didn't want to [ __ ] with him
yeah but he didn't have his social
skills well he's a fascinating dude
though yeah like i've written
i've read a couple of books about him
and like that i think that one was like
the the most interesting
because that was something that was
something that i didn't like know about
him yeah i wouldn't want to party with
him
well no no but that you know a lot of
times you have different sets of people
you want to do different things
yeah it's like these are people we party
with yeah but if we want to have a
serious conversation we're not calling
those [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
you know it's that kind of situation but
if you if you want something done
you'd probably call him you'd call him
yeah you know what i mean
you wouldn't want to like go have beer
with him though theory number four
amelia earhart crash landed was captured
by the japanese military this is a
pretty popular one
and died while being held prisoner on
the island of saipan now i think where
i had heard this one prior to this but i
think this one got bolstered a little
bit in 2017
because people that were into the amelia
earhart case they found this photograph
that had been in the national archives
and they pulled it out
and i've seen the picture and
i don't know i don't know why they got
so excited about it but okay it looks
like
um that there is it's kind of like a
dock and there's a bunch of people in
the foreground
and then in the background there's a
plane that possibly could have been
amelia earhart's plane and it was kind
of parked in this dock and then there
was like someone sitting on the end of
the dock that could have been amelia
earhart
um you know what i mean so what one
thing
[ __ ] jay marcus was like well what
bubology what about
astrology that was a good one jack
yeah the astrology yeah well you know
so yeah so i've seen this picture um
now this theory like i said it i think
it came about like back in the 60s
and i think that there was a lot of
people who lived in the marshall islands
back then
and they said apparently that they had
seen this
uh airplane land and that they saw
amelia earhart and fred noonan in
japanese custody
um and then when this picture surfaced
in 2017
everyone was like cec we told you like
they were you know they were still alive
there they are
but i think that when they dug more
into that particular photo that photo
had actually been taken
i think two years prior to amelia
earhart's flight i think it had been
taken in 1935.
so whatever the photo is of i'm pretty
sure it's not them
i'm not saying that that's not what
happened because some people did say
that they saw them but i'm just saying
that photo
is probably not them because i'm pretty
sure that that was taken two years
uh before they went on their journey my
cop friend i grew up with granters
he's going [ __ ] good interrogators
are hard to find even among police
he says uh maybe one out of 50.
that kind of reminds me that that series
that we saw that had
come that series that's supposed to be
taking place by the serial killer down
in
in louisiana had uh what was the name of
that series
where they had them uh that guy who was
uh
kinda uh remember he was killing those
girls
it was kind of like uh kind of like uh
they're do it in the folk rituals
true detective true detective yeah
remember that in true detective
yeah where um that one cop
they brought him in for questioning and
those two louisiana detectives are
sitting there just trying to get in to
talk and talk and talk
and they don't say anything through the
whole thing and and
you as an audience you think you're
being fooled by this that these are just
two louisiana country
blue gum detectives that no they're not
about anything you know what i mean
they're just country boys and then
[ __ ] what's his name the guy uh
[ __ ] that
and all of a sudden boom they got him
remember that they'd all jumped on his
ass
and the whole thing was an interrogation
yeah remember that that was a great
scene
that went on for what four or five
episodes you think those two black
detectives aren't detectives and then
all of a sudden bam they got him that
was [ __ ] great man because that's the
way you really do it well they're
getting dude to talk
and to talk you want to put people in
interest you put people at ease they'll
say [ __ ]
they wouldn't say if they were on their
guard yeah and you don't want people to
be on their guard because they won't
tell you anything the ex-cop was the
ex-detective was the [ __ ] suspect and
[ __ ] and he just and he's all confident
just going on and on and just
spinning this whole [ __ ] yarn and
trying to put him over on these two
detectives yeah they got him
that's [ __ ] great i think i got to
see that again i'm going to see that
again
eventually i'll find the other ones yeah
eventually i'll watch the other ones i
want to see the other ones too that was
good
all right uh fear number five amelia
earhart survived a pacific ocean plane
crash was secretly repatriated to new
jersey and lived
out her life under an assumed name i've
heard this one before as well
now this good one goes back to 1970
possibly earlier
but there was a book that came out in
1970 that put this one forward
so the the theory behind this is that
uh that amelia earhart did crash but
that she
survived she was taken prisoner by the
japanese but that at the end of world
war
ii uh she got found in japan by
us forces and they took her back to new
jersey and changed her identity
to a woman named irene bolem
and that she eventually became a banker
why this person that wrote this book
came up with this i'm not really sure
however
the actual woman named irene ballam who
lived in new jersey
uh she read the book and she got really
mad because she's like [ __ ] i am not
amelia earhart and she sued
uh for 1.5 million dollars uh
she withdrew the lawsuit later on uh or
she may have settled that accord i'm not
really sure
but she did actually look like amelia
earhart which
uh people actually did comment on prior
to that so maybe that's why
but apparently whoever wrote this book
like didn't ask her it's like hey i'm
just gonna say that you're amelia
earhart okay
but yeah she uh she said i'm not amelia
earhart
but maybe they told her to say that
do your own research people but you know
what i mean okay so
theory number six amelia earhart
survived and somehow made her way to
guadalcanal um so this kind of comes
from i guess in 1943
while world war ii was going on they had
a bunch of allied airmen
who said that they saw amelia earhart or
someone who looked like her
working as a nurse on guadalcanal
however uh investigation into this lead
said that the nurse that they probably
saw was a woman named merle farland
she was actually from new zealand and uh
people had told her her whole life that
she looked like amelia earhart as well
so
that might have been uh who they were
seeing so
i don't know how much credence we need
to
give to that also let's see theory
number seven
amelia earhart crashed on new britain
island
um maybe i don't know
that one's not really as uh common they
did actually
find uh an aircraft engine in 1943
that had a serial number from a pratt
and whitney
uh you know engine but that was a pretty
common
airplane engine so it might have been
from it wasn't necessarily from her
plane
so i kind of feel like even if she
crashed there they said there even
if she still had enough fuel um
there's no way she could have made it to
those islands that was like 2 000 miles
away from like where her last radio
transmission was there's like there's no
way she would have had enough fuel for
that
theory number eight this is pretty weird
amelia earhart was captured by the
japanese and became tokyo rose
that's another one that i've heard um
tokyo rose wasn't just one person it was
just kind of like a
it was like a call sign right that was
how they gave out like japanese
propaganda over the radio no
tokyo rose that was the uh japanese
propaganda girl that's what i just said
yeah now there was one main one i think
because after the war she came to the
united states to beat everybody
you know about that well yeah but there
was more than one though
that was just like a call sign that they
used yeah there's more than one but one
of them
you know evidently the one that kind of
took credit for being the main one
or at least came to the united states
and ended up soldiers airmen that were
listening to her all the time and people
that were
you know guys that were in the navy
actually went to go see her
she did like a little tour in california
yeah kind of cute yeah
she was she wasn't anti-american she was
just doing her job
well and the thing about it is like i
said there yeah there was more than one
person that did it and i think that
they kind of made them yeah you had to
do it so
of course imperial japan you did what
you were told yeah but uh
she wasn't anti-american evidently and
like liked a lot of american stuff she
spoke english
of course yeah and uh or at least they
they all did
but the one that went on tour and
evidently made a little bit of money
going on tour meeting everybody she was
like happy to [ __ ] meet everybody she
was [ __ ] broadcasting too
because did she cause there were two
guys there was no japanese guys
listening to her
yeah it was just american guys listening
so that was her audience
yeah think about it you know kind of
when you kind of eventually want to meet
your fans because evidently they liked
her they liked the tokyo rose program
yeah and they didn't really buy into
what she was saying
gi you know what i mean your your woman
is back at home [ __ ] you know
getting visitations from other people
you know while you're out here doing
this hard work
but uh from what i heard uh those gis
liked or liked the voices and wondered
what they looked like i guess but they
thought it was one woman
yeah yeah but as far as i could
determine it it was more than one woman
but that was like the call sign that
they used that that's like the name that
they used yeah
all right so you talk about something
i'm gonna go to the bathroom and then
when we come back
we're gonna talk about the anthill kids
yeah but yeah you you've been you teased
this one pretty hard i wanna i wanna
hear what this is about this is [ __ ]
up how long is that gonna take i don't
know not that one okay
just but i dreams hold and so it'll be
fine yeah well don't
don't jinx it i'm jinxing it by you
mentioning it yes i need that something
see she's gonna blame me if this [ __ ]
[ __ ] crap
well i'll always okay all right so i'm
going to the bathroom so talk about
something
oh my god it's still daylight up yeah
grab there's a season one
well i think season two and season one
and season two
were the same story right i think that
took see two seasons for it
i think that was two seasons for it
wasn't it did that take two seasons to
actually explain the whole story
maybe just one i got i got it on um
blu-ray but i thought i thought it was
two seasons
for the first story with matthew
mcconaughey
see what everybody doing i should have
brought my hats
because i'm probably at about level
three right now
i'm pretty [ __ ] up i want
wanting to hear this uh story about the
ant hill
kids
everybody's in the comment section
talking about what pets they have
snakes and rabbits and [ __ ] tila's
talking about her rabbits
what is it she used to have several
rabbits
but they were chewing up cords and stuff
let's see
they're also talking about reptiles
owning reptiles
oh [ __ ] that's right tina said i might
be on mit
wig mode i'm gonna [ __ ] get a wig
that's right i got wigs right here
i got wigs right here uh oh yeah
wig bring the hats
oh [ __ ] we're going like right we're
going we're bypassing all the
all the defcon hats and going right
right
going right to like energy going
straight to the apocalypse
let me see if i can fix this [ __ ] i
can't take you seriously when you're
wearing that
oh no but maybe that's good yeah that's
good
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
do some rubber plant
everybody's like wig wig wig oh my god i
was going to wear
the lady who knows all that glitters
is gold and she's buying a stairway
to heaven oh my god
you're a ridiculous person
[Laughter]
rings of smoke through the trees till it
says wiggles
and the forest will echo with laughter
and it makes me want to man led deadpool
are the only [ __ ] that could like
sing about [ __ ] jrr tolkien and not
be like
called nerds it was back then yeah back
then
i mean you know back then
those dudes were [ __ ] high everyone
was hiding back then so it all worked
out glasses
on this [ __ ] it all worked out there we
go
this just [ __ ] oh man didn't make a
statue of me like this is david
you know um you kind of look more like a
mildred
well just like a general mildred like an
old baby you know yeah
you look like an old lady kind of i
could put a moo moo on xanada said
you should tom that wig really pulls
your look together
just like the rug and the big lebowski
pulling the rim together
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] man tom needs a mullet wig oh
my god you totally do
yeah get me one okay do you guys want
just for my i'm going to write it you
guys i'm writing it wear it
send me a wig oh oh i got
put a wig on seriously you guys need to
send some really [ __ ] up wigs because
i'm going to remember this
immigration i'm remembering that you
said that
i can't do that they come to the end of
the ice and snow
[Laughter]
and i'll remember thank you of the gods
our ships to new land oh my god fight
the horde
sing and cry
i am coming
[Laughter]
you can tell it's friday night right
yeah holy [ __ ]
friday night and we had like soul food
today and he's just all full of beans
you had your chicken and waffles earlier
man i need to smoke
i have my shrimp and grits i only gonna
be in the western show
oh my god you're so embarrassing no i'm
just kidding
xanada says i'm still so i'm so stoned
and this is making my day
is that that's not the last no well
there's only four left
because you smoked all my [ __ ] you
smoked all my [ __ ]
he smoked almost i'm i'm picking out old
ones that
still got [ __ ] on them because i don't
have i gotta buy a new one
tom needs an unplugged live right
i mean just me singing yeah
no i would never work it would never
work i don't know the lyrics
well you can just make them up that's
what you usually do
as we usually do what is grits by the
way
says gadgey3 dude you know what grace is
glad non-sub
[Laughter]
grits are like okay do you know what
polenta is
it's kind of like you call it redneck
polenta yeah
first of all you have to understand the
time in which grits are in season
grit trees are in bloom in the spring
all right when grit when grit trees come
in bloom
a bunch of fairies and elves go around
the bottom of them like they're in the
damn maypool
like they're in the maypole and then
they pull out trash bags and they catch
the grits as they fall gently to the
ground
kind of like japanese cherry blossom
festival thank you tila and then from
that
you take the cherry blossom grit grit
blossoms
and you give them to a bunch of cats
and it kind of has like a catnip effect
on them and they tear them all up
and then you dry it
and then and then after that i don't
know
wow this is a roller coaster ride isn't
it
seriously it's harmony they soak it in
lie
which is kind of it's cattle feed
essentially they don't know what comedy
is
it's like it's sort of like comedy of
corn it's kind of like corn yet
what you do is you take dried cracked
corn that you would feed cattle
you take that and you put that in a
barrel full of lye
with a bunch of water and a lie and it
pops like popcorn but it
but it's wet it's like wet popcorn and
that's called hominy
you take the hominy out and then you
grind it
into a paste and then you dry the paste
and it turns into grits
you can rehydrate it and it goes back
into that paste
that's what it is gramster says why are
the grits at ihop so grossly and edible
they don't season them they don't know
how to make them
they don't season them i think well one
they just use instant ones which
are fine but instant ones you have to
know how to season them though you can't
just eat them plain
they have an ashtray one of them where's
this coffin ashtray
it's over there so i'm gonna keep that
one can i give grits to yankees
okay well and the thing about you don't
know anything about grits well and grits
you have to know what to do with them
you can't just eat them plain it tastes
like wallpaper paste
you gotta [ __ ] put like seasoning and
like other [ __ ] in it
you know
you give grits to [ __ ] rednecks and
black people they'll make them taste
good
they know what to do with them i mean
the one i had shrimp and grits at
chantals today and that [ __ ] was
yeah divine man it was so
so good i'm gonna get a video next time
i go down there me and chantelle gonna
hang out i'm gonna [ __ ] show you i'm
gonna order that again
i'm gonna order that i'll make a whole
video about that
make a whole video about that grit grits
and shrimp
i mean he got chicken and waffles which
is also good because i had that last
time i was there it's also delicious
but he was like he ate some of my shrimp
and grits because i couldn't eat at all
because
and he was just like oh i'm gonna i
gotta get that next time
oh in the hands of the right kind of
cook
shrimp and grits or grits just any kind
of grits
done right southern
or soul style which is the same thing
red
that shrimp and grits that she gave her
with that catfish on the side would have
been
something that you would have got in in
a five michelin star restaurant in
europe
they would have called it something else
all fancy you know what i mean but
that's what it was
they would have loved that
those shrimp came in a state in a cajun
seasoned sauce that was based in butter
it was just beautiful and it mixed in
with those cheese grits
and then you had fried catfish on the
side of it and there was also like i
said onions and bell peppers onions and
bell peppers
sauteed with shrimp really good
kind of like a polenta dish yeah it was
fantastic
i mean so grits are porridge now
i mean it's a similar thank you gadget
cigarettes are poured yeah
not really well it's a similar um
consistency
it's corn
it's corn it has a a different texture
you're not doing wheat it's uh
almost like imagine if you took risotto
and blended it slightly that's what it
would be like more like that
more like a risotto that's been
immersion blended just slightly to take
to get rid of the the grains so they
were pieces of grain it'd be like that
yeah it would be corn it has a slight
corn taste to it
and like i said it's all in what you and
how you season it and what you put with
it because it's just kind of like rice
if you eat it plain it's kind of blah
but it's like
if you put other things with it i mean
you know
yeah detroit people eat oh poutine
french fries with cheese curds dallas
and gravy yeah yeah i've heard about
that but i've never eaten it
it sounds good though yeah
i would eat that that sounds good
but you know what i mean all right
you done with grits yeah can we talk
about this [ __ ] they asked about
which i answered the question
you know if if that didn't answer the
great questions i don't know what did
what would
it's just like uh
it's like polenta yeah i feel like
that's probably the cool thing
that's closest approximation yeah and
like i said in philadelphia a bunch of
different ways to see it's like a cajun
seasoned
polenta with cheese in it and [ __ ]
pieces of meat you know like
chopped up slices of fried bacon or or
or
grits with with
you know fluff jelly you know i know
i'm you know and they're they should
strip and have a little shrimp in it you
know
yeah you can do whatever you want pieces
of
ham oh that's real good we put
hard-boiled eggs in it
yeah hard-boiled eggs red-eye gravy on
it put bacon in there
or you know actually i call it red-eye
gravy it's actually called tomato gravy
wasn't that right tomato gravy yeah well
because there's two versions
red eye gravy is generally just like
coffee ground yes
well it's yeah it's not coffee grounds
it's actual like black coffee
like out of the box yeah mixed with
like pork drippings yeah more comments
tomato gravy we'll call that red eye
gravy too some type so
yeah i think i explained that in the
cookbook actually it's in a cookbook
you'll see
yeah i'll talk about it which is which
is actually almost all i got to do is i
took all the pictures
and i have like i have to cut you out of
the backgrounds i did that on like three
or four pictures but i still have a
couple more to do and then it'll be
finished you're making fun of me that
i'm hammered i'm losing track now i am
let me get a lighter again it went out
okay it's like coffee gravy rocks never
had tomato gravy
yeah it's similar but yeah red eye gravy
is usually
coffee like black coffee in tomato gravy
no
it's black coffee and the [ __ ] the pork
grease is what it is
too i haven't seen it in a long time
some versions have tomato
but not many of them yeah usually like
the technical one is my dad used to make
it with tomato
i mean that's why it's called red-eye
gravy is because caffeine can't be
yeah yeah
had a ham bone in one of them that might
have been in tomato gravy
yeah all right so let's get into this
i'm very excited to get into this cult
come on here like [ __ ] let's do it
all right thank you finally all right so
like i said
this has been recommended a couple of
times and i came across this cult just
accidentally when i was looking up some
other [ __ ] and i can't believe this
shit's not better known because this
[ __ ]
is crazy okay this [ __ ] is crazy
so the dude that started this cult which
is called the ant hill kids and i'll
explain why it's called that later
this dude was a french canadian named
rock or rock therio
that was his name now
this is one of those things where you
know how cults and they always kind of
start as like a cool thing it's like
yeah man we're like he uh we're a
religious cult we're all and we don't
drink and
we're all into healthy food and all that
kind of crap and then later on
um you know some really horrible like
torture and murder and [ __ ] occurs
okay well that's what happened in this
case so
i saw myself on my tablet i look like
david koresh
i look like david correct speaking of
crazy cult leaders
he's gonna try and start a cult in this
house
and then yeah okay but then i'm just
going to look at him and go hmm
no oh oatmeal cream pie it's time for me
to
bust open the little debbies i just saw
that over there and i was just like when
is he gonna eat that
for all you european people let me show
you some fancy
delicacy this is made by little debbies
this is this is
the oatmeal cream pie i'm not a big fan
of those like i'll eat them if nobody's
got any other ones but
as far as little debbie goes not my
favorite it is two soft oatmeal cookies
with marshmallow in the middle of it
yeah see i'm not a big fan of
marshmallow i think right now
i can't believe it's like 350 calories
probably i can't believe you're eating
again
because you not only ate your chick all
your chicken and waffles
yeah you ate some of my shrimp and grits
because i couldn't eat it all and you
ate nana pudding
yeah and now you're eating that it's
like 3 000 calorie day
it is i don't know how you do i don't
know where you put it you must have a
hollow leg
that's what my grandma used to say
so all right so this psychopath
we'll call him rock i said i'm not sure
if it's rogue or rock
i've heard it pronounced both ways but
we'll call him rock just because that's
funnier
so he's born in quebec in 1947. now his
parents
hyacinth who i think was his dad
which that's a crazy name but okay and
pirate was his mom
now his childhood i guess his parents
were like
catholic but they were like super
catholic they were one of those
weird offshoot super super
super right wing catholic groups they
were called the white berets
and they were really really um
i don't know it was like this really
weird i've seen it even called like
fascistic even
so his parents were in that
now rock later on
would say that his parents were super
abusive to him like we're physically
abusive and [ __ ] like that
i don't know if that's entirely true
because the problem about rock therio
is that he had um
i mean he wasn't diagnosed with this at
the time but
in hindsight it seemed like he probably
had like narcissistic personality
disorder
and he was real big on uh
playing the victim all the time so i
think that one of the things that he
would do
was cry poor me like my parents were so
abusive and [ __ ] like that but i don't
know if that's the case i think that his
parents were
weirdos but i don't think they'd like
beat him up or anything like that
so anyway uh so he grows up in this like
weird
like super super strict like religious
household
he drops out of school at 13 and then
starts getting obsessed with
uh the old testament particularly like
apocalyptic kind of [ __ ]
now by all accounts uh he was a very
very
intelligent kid
but the thing about him was that he
seemed also
to be as i said very narcissistic in the
sense that
even from a fairly young age uh he felt
like
he kind of came across like he knew
everything knew everybody
you know knew everything like more than
everybody is what i meant to say
um but on the other hand also
pretty charismatic like it didn't really
seem that he had much trouble like
getting
women and [ __ ] like that now after he
left home he really didn't like the
super strict catholic [ __ ]
but he sort of made a little bit of a
lateral move
in going into the seventh day adventists
now the seventh day adventists if you
don't know are an offshoot of the
[ __ ]
millerates oh yeah those are awesome the
millerites
were the dudes it was it was that dude
yeah it was the time
yeah it was an end time called and like
the the dude that started it was kind of
like oh
the world is seriously gonna end like
right now you guys need to like sell all
your possessions we're going to the top
of this mountain we're waiting for jesus
or whatever
obviously it didn't happen and the
people that
like a lot of the people were like man
[ __ ] you that's you lied and they left
but the people that stayed they um
justified the [ __ ] in a way that they
were kind of oh well
um you know he was probably right about
that maybe he was just like wrong about
the date or whatever we'll figure it out
and those people became seventh-day
adventists so that's where we're coming
from i think i told you that my dad
has a hard back book from the miller
rights
that he got through his family somehow
over the years
and i think it might be from those times
very early 1900s it's called
rightly dividing the word i remember it
i tried to read it and make
sense of it the entire book is all
all focused around the book of
revelations and in the pre-internet era
back in the late 90s i was just totally
[ __ ] fascinated
it was like some nostradamus [ __ ]
well yeah he's going through some of
those old testament
to some of the old testament prophecies
like the one about the the statue with
the clay feet
the gold head and the clay feet yeah he
tried to explain all that
and then he starts to explain you know
the the beast with the seven heads and
what's cool about the book is that it
unfolds in a bunch of maps
showing what what leads to what
and then it has like what bible verse in
revelation
something is mentioned like you know
what i mean like the uh
the beast and the [ __ ] the [ __ ] of
babylon and then you know the
one what seal gets opened and what that
god said when that's
what the lamb said when that seals open
so it's like
there's a flow chart you know what i'm
talking about
there's an apocalyptic flow chart in the
book okay i was tripping
it's like oh my god this is like man it
might happen you don't know what
happened that's gonna happen the
antichrist
it's not gonna happen the antichrist
well you know my understanding of it now
is
uh a lot better it's roman they're
talking about the fall the roman empire
didn't have anything to do with
modern day yeah obviously yeah they
didn't know anything they didn't know
[ __ ] about [ __ ] back then
why people still like looking like [ __ ]
they said back then
they didn't know anything the eastern
orthodox christians they're stupider
than [ __ ] nowadays and nowadays
people are pretty [ __ ] stupid
well it was an encoded message oh you
know they were it was telling the
christians of rome that
that the time would be over soon you
know that type of stuff but anyway um
so it's out it's out of context but the
um
what's funny is that christians here
assume that all christians have the book
of revelations the eastern orthodox
doesn't have it
they say it was well yeah they're all
the versions are like they're a little
bit different
yeah because the eastern orthodox was
like that's a prophecy that didn't
happen so they didn't have it in there
you know we're just like just because
you don't have well
it's a selection of works sure that's
always fun
so yeah so he got involved in the
seventh-day adventist church which i
think
i think what attracted him to that maybe
was that
i think he liked it because he had maybe
uh some early kind of [ __ ] that he was
maybe going to be alcoholic which
spoiler alert kind of happened later on
but he liked the whole like clean living
kind of [ __ ] because the seventh-day ad
venice at the time
and maybe nowadays i'm not really sure
but um they don't smoke they don't drink
uh they don't eat processed foods they
like a really healthy like vegetarian
diet
so he kind of got into into that
right what yeah you see is the tom your
hair is gorgeous and beautiful
it's just like usually like flinging
around like you're in a [ __ ]
beautiful yeah like you're in a suave or
something yeah i'm [ __ ]
um i'm uh the lead singer of the doors
now
you don't look anything like jim
morrison
i have no idea what you're talking about
right now
you wanted something approximating jim
morrison harry you might do some i don't
know like maybe like michael landon from
the [ __ ] from
little house of the prairie or something
that was kind of similar
um yeah so so he gets in with the
seventh day adventist but
because he seemed like allegedly a
little bit of a narcissist
um he immediately started like to try to
take over the [ __ ] like he's gonna be
like
you know trying to get in a leadership
position and uh
i guess like a lot of the elders weren't
having it so they were like yeah get the
[ __ ] out of here
so what ended up happening with that is
he said well he's like you know i'm
gonna start my own
religion with blackjack and hookers and
uh
you know not really but with torture and
murder more in this case
uh but so some people did actually uh
end up
following following him from his uh
split so mid 1970s
roll around and by this point
this dude rock had either convinced
himself
or convinced other people
that he was uh you know the savior
of the universe like many cult leaders
do
like i said he had a thing where he kind
of thought he was better than everyone
uh he was smarter than everyone and
some people bought into it i guess like
i said he was really charismatic
so he thought that god had put him on
the earth to save the world from evil
and that he was going to save his chosen
followers
from the coming apocalypse because he
was a very apocalyptic
uh type of dude type of thinker like a
very and it's interesting too because i
feel like some of the [ __ ] that happened
with his cult
like happened a year or two only a year
or two like after the jonestown
[ __ ] so he seemed like well aware of
that
but it almost kind of went in the same
direction except you know even
horrific like in a different way i don't
know crazy
but so what he's gonna do he decides
he's gonna start a commune because like
i said it's 70s that's what they were
all doing back then
um now initially
it's always like with these cults it's
always like oh initially it started out
kind of cool because like i said
people's temple like the jonestown thing
that started out kind of cool we're
going to live out in the woods going to
build our own [ __ ] we're going to be
self-sufficient
you know everyone's going to be equal
it's going to be awesome and it was like
awesome for a little while
till it wasn't and i kind of feel like
that's what happened here
because i feel like his initial thing
was yeah everybody's gonna be equal it's
gonna be awesome
[ __ ] like that however uh this one
seemed to
progress into like shittiness a lot
quicker than uh jonestown did
so basically from the four he didn't
have a [ __ ] ton of followers but the
followers he had seemed pretty loyal
so he's like well um you guys uh you
know the apocalypse is coming we're
gonna live in a commune it's gonna be
awesome but
you um need to like not live in your
houses you can't talk to your family or
friends anymore because they're like a
bad
influence you know that's they're part
of the evil
world and everyone's going to be wiped
out and blah blah so
he had that kind of thing going on so he
got them all to like abandon their
families and whatnot because they he
thought they were corrupt
so uh you know and he came across as
like their
messiah figure and then he said
that the world was going to end in
february
of 1979.
so at this point to get ready for this
world ending man remember when the world
ended in february 1979 i sure remember
that
uh so he decides that like his followers
at that time like i said he didn't have
that many
four dudes nine women and four children
they moved to this place called that
they called the eternal mountain
which was near a gaspe village in uh
saint
joeg i want to say this like i said this
is around quebec
uh you know so french canadian kind of
area
so at this point they build a commune
they they build like a bunch of big log
cabins tents [ __ ] like that
the reason they're called the ant hill
kids i'm gonna say that right now
is because uh rock gave them that name
because of course his followers he's
like hey
why don't you guys go out and build some
cabins big enough to house everybody i'm
just going to sit back here and look at
you because i'm god and whatnot
um and he said it's like oh they look
like little ants
like working because he made them like
work all the time to like build [ __ ] and
do [ __ ] for him
right yeah so that's what he called them
he called them the anthill kids
which seems a little insulting but they
didn't really seem to take it that way
so uh so they worked their asses off all
the time
they built this commune of log cabins or
whatever
uh so obviously february of 1979 comes
and goes
and spoiler alert the world didn't end
now uh rock actually
justified this as they always do by
saying oh well
um the world didn't end because uh
the israelite calendar and the roman
catholic calendar are different and i
like kind of [ __ ] it up but it's like
it didn't you know what i mean
yeah rock out it can happen yeah and i'm
just kind of like okay so that bought it
some more time
yeah sure um but at this point
okay so like i feel like he didn't have
a lot of followers but
they hung around right so he's like what
he
decided to do at this point because i
guess they bought that [ __ ]
and he was like now at this point any of
you guys that are married to each other
okay those marriages are now dissolved
and now everybody's going to marry me
like all the women are going to marry
him because it's a cult and that's what
they do
so he ended up he married all the women
in the commune
and impregnated all of them so ended up
fathering 20 children
by nine different women
now here's the shitty part like i said
this
started out i was watching a documentary
about this
in which he talked about the frog and
boiling water thing because like you
know how people like are like how the
[ __ ] could you ever join a cult where
xyz happens it's like horrific [ __ ]
it's like well it doesn't happen from
the [ __ ] beginning
does it it's like you get into it and
it's slowly
and it's slowly like you know it's just
like when we talk about scientology a
lot you get into scientology it's like
oh
a communications course this seems
helpful they do this that the other
thing
it's only very very slowly they kind of
just like and cult leaders totally know
that
so they don't like bring out the big
guns like hey i'm god i'm gonna marry
and like [ __ ] all your kids kind of [ __ ]
they don't
bring that out like right from the
outset that's what they want to do
but they know not to lead with that you
know what i mean
and that's kind of what happened here it
was kind of this kind of thing was like
we're going to be a healthy cult we're
going to live
away from the corrupt world we're going
to eat healthy food
we're going to live off the grid we're
going to do and that was very appealing
to peop to you know certain types of
people back then
it wasn't horrible from the outset and i
was listening to an interview with um
a woman who had actually been in this
cult and like she got out later and she
wrote a
book about it and she said pretty much
the same thing she's like
it just gets to a point where it you
know it's so
incremental that you're getting to a
point of like you know torture murder
[ __ ] like that
and you know you've gone through every
step through this and it's just kind of
like you accept every step every
separate step and it's just kind of like
the next step you know what i mean
so it's just keep that in mind
so so he marries all the women
uh starts banging all of them bothering
children left and right and now
did he marry uh however many were in the
cult i think they were like
the uh so he married all the women yeah
yeah i am like i said he dissolved all
the all the marriages oh yeah he stole
everybody's wife okay he stole
everyone's wife well
he he said pretty much god told him to
yeah yeah
now at this point okay so
even though like the seventh-day
adventists as i said
are very anti-alcohol they don't drink
now he kind of skirted that a little bit
where he was a social drinker
he also had some health issues i think
he had like some kind of um
stomach ulcers and [ __ ] like that so he
was like in constant pain
because i think he was married to a
woman for a long time and she said that
after he'd had
surgery for the stomach ulcers
uh his personality changed right like he
turned into like he'd been okay prior to
that
but then like he'd kind of been like
arrogant and like a narcissist
before that but it was still you could
still deal with it whereas after that
it's almost kind of like he went into
like total psychopath
type of mode also he started drinking
all the time and they said when he was
drinking he was just like a [ __ ]
psychopath
right so what happens at this point so
the commune's going on for a couple
years
the first thing that happened that was
kind of like a
bellwether of things to come 1981
there's this two-year-old kid at the
commune which was the kid of one of the
members and the kid's name was samuel
gilgaer
now the little boy had some kind of
problem or he
like he was having a hard time peeing
right
so rock decides um
because he was a total [ __ ]
narcissist and they said when he drank
he was the worst
he thought that he even though he had no
medical training
he thought that he could just do like
surgeries on people and it would just
you know fly like he could figure it out
so he decided that what this little
boy's
problem was that well he needs to be
uh circumcised okay yeah that's all he
needs
um for whatever reason yeah so
he ends up you gotta be circumcised yeah
makes a lot of sense
so he ends up slicing open
this two-year-old boy's penis
that's not circumcision though no but he
didn't know what he was doing
right he was drunk and he was also kind
of an idiot who thought he was smart
yeah right so which is a very very
dangerous combination
ann thought he's like oh what's surgery
how hard can it be yeah
he was that kind of [ __ ] so he
did that now
um he's doing that and obviously this
two-year-old boy is screaming his head
off as you would
right so brock says
to one of his followers whose name was
guy veer
oh well the kid's crying so why don't
you beat the [ __ ] out of him until he
stops crying like to punish him
that's killing him kid
yeah guess what it did it killed the kid
right yes
uh the follower did as he was told
because like i said at this point they'd
been in the
commune for a couple of years right and
we're all pretty much indoctrinated and
followed whatever he said they beat the
kid until the kids stop crying which
means the kid is dead
yeah dumbasses yeah yeah so this little
two-year-old kid died from the injuries
from the beating and from the
uh penis slicing which yeah oh it gets
better
folks so at this point they're like oh
well [ __ ] we better do something to
uh you know cover that up so then they
set the kids body on fire
um and also because guy veer the guy
that had beat the kid
didn't do it right or didn't uh
something or killed the kid or whatever
uh rock decided he was gonna punish that
guy too so we
castrated him oh yeah it makes sense
yeah
and then he said that well if anyone
asks
just say he was trampled by a horse yeah
because they did have some [ __ ] and
some like some horses like that on the
property yeah so you know
that explains it now the weird thing
about this is that apparently the cops
like raided the commune at this point
and they did find
the kid's body um so rock and
a bunch of the other followers i think
eight of them were got arrested and
charged
at the time but they all ended up
getting released
which was unfortunate for everyone
involved because even worse [ __ ] would
come down the pipeline it gets worse
it does so after they got released they
decided they were just getting two
persecuted man
and so they go to burnt river ontario
and establish a community like out in
the middle of the [ __ ] woods right
where they think no one's gonna bother
them they can do whatever the [ __ ] they
want to and they did
so at this point uh there were actually
you know he didn't have a great amount
of followers like i said now 26 of the
followers quote
were children and a lot of them were his
because like i said he had fathered a
lot of uh
children by all of the women in the
commune right
now at this point they're supporting
themselves by
making stuff they'd make bread and
preserves and stuff like that and they
sold them in this little shop that they
had
and they called it like the ant hill
kids store like anthill kids like arts
and crafts or whatever little shop of
[ __ ]
yeah pretty much so that's kind of how
they made money i don't imagine they
made that much money but that's
how they supported themselves by selling
you know things that they made
those weird germans down in argentina
made a living
or was it yeah argentina remember that
yeah community dignidad
that dude was a pedo too trying to keep
kids from going into puberty
yeah weird [ __ ] yeah on that we're gonna
do a show well yeah i do keep putting it
in the poll
we'll see how it goes shoot it do you
all right so when they first moved to
the community everyone thought they were
just kind of charming man it's like oh
look at these little like
self-sufficient
dudes living out in the woods they're
all like [ __ ] rugged
you know making maple syrup and growing
stuff and selling it and everybody
thought it was kind of cool like they
even got like
you know some media attention whatnot
however what they didn't know
was that rock therio was over there
drinking even more and more
uh you know and getting even more and
more
violent at this point he decides
that he's going to start uh
cracking down even more on the followers
he forbids them to talk to each other
without his permission they can't talk
to each other at all uh and then he
implemented gladiator tournaments so he
made them fight each other
um in a dirt ring with what fists
i guess um then he started
like beating them first he'd start like
with your regular [ __ ] like a belt
then he started hitting them with
hammers damn then he started hitting
them with the blunt side of
axes just cuz this motherfucker's going
crazy and then
this is i'm telling you this you're just
like putting up with it i guess
like i said they've been there for years
and years yeah um
now if someone was thinking about
leaving which some of them did
at the time like i said i saw a couple
of people that survived that were like
talking about it
so if he heard that somebody thought
about they were leaving he would
tie them up to the ceiling like rope
them to the ceiling
yeah and then he would pluck out all
their hairs one by one
and then poop on them yeah that makes
sense
and then and then
he would ask them he's like if you are
loyal to me and if you love me because
i'm god or whatever
then take this sledgehammer and break
your own
legs and they did it damn
they did it nuts he would also tell them
to do things like
uh sit on a lit stove damn
shoot each other in the arm [ __ ] smear
[ __ ] on one another
damn cut off each other's toes jeez
um yeah one of the one of the followers
came forward and said yeah
they had cut off someone else's pinky
toe because he told them to damn
um obviously he was sexually abusing
uh everyone in the cults uh women
children
uh he would make them eat their own [ __ ]
damn
he was a scatterphile also yeah um
another thing he would do too if the
kids pissed him off
he would nail them to a tree and make
the other kids and their parents throw
rocks at them
damn so you know um
and there was a point too it was
charming yeah there was this one really
[ __ ] sad story like this woman
because she had uh you know she had
several kids there and she had just had
a baby it was like a newborn
and um she was like kind of over it she
was like i need to get the [ __ ] out of
here
and she's like i'm your baby yeah and
well the thing about it this is what's
[ __ ] sad
is that she's like i would rather the
baby be dead than like live here under
the [ __ ] she left the baby outside in
the cold and first
oh damn because she was like
yeah we can't live like she couldn't
leave you know what i mean
now this particular death did actually
lead to an investigation
so in 1987 the authorities came in huh
there anymore in there
i don't know find them in 1987 uh the
authorities came in
and they took uh 14 children out of the
compound right and they put them in
foster homes
but they didn't really do anything
further i mean that's good
that they did that but they didn't
really um
you know follow up too much on it
but 14 of them were gone so at least
something so the commune was still there
uh all that was left at this point was
[ __ ] rock theria the [ __ ]
psychopath leader two dudes and eight
women
and the remaining children now after
those 14 children were taken
away rock started like drinking even
more
and becoming even more violent and as i
said
he thought that he was a [ __ ]
surgeon right so he decided
he just did this [ __ ] like it almost
seems like he was just doing it on a
lark
so like one day he goes up to one of the
male members of which there were only
two
and he's like hey i'm gonna put a rubber
band around your testicle
and see if like see how long it takes to
like fall off or whatever
damn and they did it it's like he put
the rubber band around this
around the dude's scrote and it became
swollen and infected
about eight hours later then he took the
testicle off
and then cauterize the wound with an
iron damn
so and people are like letting him do it
right now this [ __ ] okay so this is
[ __ ] up too
this is [ __ ] up september of 1988
there was a woman in his uh commune
named solange
boilard boilard something like that i
took french for four years but i don't
remember a lot of it
now she had been complaining about
having a stomachache right which is
something you didn't want to do around
this dude apparently because he thought
he could just fix everything and he
would just fix it in the worst way
imaginable
so she said that she had a stomachache
so he's like well i can fix your
problems
what cis says with the glasses on and
look like [ __ ] tootsie for [ __ ]
that's what i was thinking yeah you look
like i was thinking harpo marks somebody
can ride that [ __ ] give me give me a
light
let me get that well yeah you know she's
going out
yeah well he's always just kind of like
he waits and i don't have them
again well i got there's another one in
there i don't have a lighter get your
own
no yeah
oh my god so okay so solange like i said
she complained that she had stomach ache
so
rock says i can fix that so she comes
into the kitchen he puts her up on the
[ __ ] bakery table
right and
okay so he starts punching her in the
stomach
because that'll fix it and then
he shoved a plastic tube up her ass
and gave her an enema with molasses and
olive oil
he also took a tube and shoved it down
her throat
and him and the other followers like
started
breathing into it like like blowing into
it and sucking
up out of it trying to blow it out her
ass
right but like sucking up into it too
and i'm just like how like what the [ __ ]
man they thought she was blocked up why
did he even think of this she thought
she was blocked up
why didn't even think of this
so she's got a tube up her ass that has
molasses and olive oil in it and
there's like a tube down her throat i
can kind of understand the olive oil but
the molasses why the molasses
you think that wouldn't what do you give
me i don't know ridiculous oh my god i'm
trying to get something out of her
clear clear out probably should have
just made her drink a whole bunch of
olive oil it probably would have been
enough actually so if that wasn't bad
enough she's got a tube up her ass
a tube down her throat that they've all
been blowing in yeah
and then brock decides oh well i guess
that's not enough so then he
cuts open the side of her abdomen what
pulls out a little bit of her intestine
with his bare hands yeah rips a piece of
it
off damn and then stuck the rest of it
in there
damn and then he's like that's
yeah and then you told somebody else hey
sew that back up bye
yeah did she die yes yeah man so
yes and she died in horrible horrible
pain it took her several hours to die
yeah and they were probably the worst
hours that she ever i mean can you
[ __ ] imagine
well they think it was because all that
obviously all the digestive chemicals
were wrapping
into her abdominal cavity jesus [ __ ]
christ
and what was she complaining of again
she just said oh her stomach hurt
that's all it was yes [ __ ] [ __ ]
probably starvation
who knows it could have been anything
she could have just like
yeah it's like she could have just eaten
something i mean [ __ ] hell
now if that wasn't bad at this poor
woman so she died the next day
and then brock was like well guess what
you guys
i can resurrect her right
he gives a regular he's gonna resurrect
her
how he resurrected her okay
the first thing was that he had a bunch
of his followers come in
he cuts open her abdomen again and
removes her uterus
just for shits and giggles apparently
some jack the ripper [ __ ]
and then he sawed
off part of her skull and had all the
male members including him
jerk off into her skull cavity
yeah that'll fix it
i'm a horror writer and i never came up
with anything like come on man
this motherfucker's obviously he's
jerking off into a hole
in a dead woman's skull to replay did i
just say that sentence out loud i did
he's trying to replant the seeds of life
it made
sense to him i suppose
yeah so him and the other two dudes
ejaculated into her brain
threw a hole in her skull because they
thought that would bring her back to
life
or that's what he said anyway these
[ __ ] have suffered some very
serious religious
delusions wow how long have they been on
this [ __ ] compound by this time
well this was in the early 80s and
they'd been on their like sin no it's
been since like 1977. okay something
like that so a few
years so that [ __ ] [ __ ] escalated
rapidly
yeah okay that's what i'm saying like at
first it all seemed like yeah we're all
gonna be vegetarians and not smoke and
drink and it'll be super fun and healthy
and then all of a sudden oh we're
jerking off into a dead woman's brain
how does that happen i have a very good
understanding of religion
how does that happen religions and cults
and the cult mentality god says so it
didn't work
wouldn't that be something if it did
work no it didn't work obviously
that's dennis raider level the right
that's what i was thinking that's why i
don't know why like this dude's not
better known because that's like some
serial killer [ __ ] right there
they're not seeing it that way though
it's a religious delusion he's slightly
[ __ ] psychotic
slightly yeah he's psychotic well you
have some people that get involved into
weird religious
delusions that don't have any mental
problems
at first but then
like there's a uh they kind of induce a
mental illness into themselves
almost kind of like a mass psychosis
there's a bunch of people believing
things at once
altogether you know that's what happened
kinda in a way of scientology wasn't
quite as bad as this
but well when you're surrounded by other
people who are
reinforcing yeah exactly um
and like i said i was watching kind of a
psychological breakdown of people
these people in particular but people
that you know get into cults
like i said it's not like you just waltz
into the door of the cult or whatever
and they're like hey let's jerk off into
a dead brain
exactly the person the person in charge
sees what they can get away with and
that becomes the new normal and then a
little bit later it's ratcheted up again
so the new normal actually gets tighter
and tighter and tighter
that's why when you hear [ __ ] people
people with authority start talking well
you have to get used to a new normal
don't listen to those [ __ ]
you dictate what new normal is for you
in your life
at that don't let other people dictate
to you what normal should be
well as i said you it you know it's easy
to get sucked into these kind of groups
where you know it's just [ __ ] keeps
escala and and dudes like this like rock
theriot clearly
a narcissistic psychopath and
he's just he's got his own little
fantasies i guess
and these people have been with him so
long
that and they really believe that he has
some kind of divine power so
he you know it started out small at
first like i said and a lot of people
said that he didn't really get bad
until after the surgery that he had on
his ulcers which
kind of like changed his personality
because he was in chronic pain all the
time
and so he started drinking a lot to
self-medicate
and that really exacerbated his violence
so i'm not saying that he wasn't a
psychopath from the beginning he
probably was
but i think that him being in constant
pain and him being like drunk all the
time um
just like you know removed his in any
inhibitions he might have had
to act in that particular way so so yeah
so he tries to bring the woman back
obviously it didn't work
jerking off into some in a dead person's
skull does not bring them back to life
um
pro tip so just in case you were
thinking of trying it
but when you think you're god you think
that you have the power of life and
death that you can bring somebody back
to life
yeah i mean he probably actually
believed he could
he must have i don't you know i don't
know what this dude's [ __ ] problem
was yeah
yeah so not only so obviously it didn't
work so
um he told like his followers hey just
like bury her
out on the grounds or whatever but first
i'm going to take part of that sweet rib
cage so i can wear it as a necklace
because that's something that you do you
know
now later on that year november of 1988
there's another member of the commune
whose name is uh gabrielle lavali
lavalie uh and i actually saw an
interview with her
on a documentary about them so she's uh
she's still alive or at least she was
when the uh
one of those people just like regular
ads
yeah so she comes to him
and again pro tip don't ever tell this
dude that you feel bad
because he thinks that he can fix your
[ __ ] and it's going to be the most
horrific
even though he's killed what two or
three people by now yeah a baby and an
adult
yep i wouldn't trust that [ __ ]
well no but
like i said i think they were all kind
of like they were all in this weird
mindset
yeah so she comes to rock
and says that she has a toothache
so uh what what do you think might have
happened
rock decides i can fix that he tore out
a bunch of her teeth with pliers
a bunch of them yeah several not just
the hurting one
but the [ __ ] yeah well you know never
these ones might hurt too at some point
might as well just like get ahead at
getting it don't pull out teeth with
pliers that's not how it's done
well obviously you're done with the jack
which is just a spot
obviously put his bike underneath him
but you better be fast and you better
have [ __ ]
he's well the pr his problem was and i
was like watching the thing about this
his problem was i think that he thought
he knew everything yeah
no he thought he knew everything yeah he
didn't have internet he couldn't check
he's just like
yeah spirits were gonna tell him yeah
that's what he thought yeah
so okay so it wasn't bad enough that he
pulled out a bunch of her teeth with
pliers that's bad enough
then he decided later on that
i don't know if this had anything to do
with curing her toothache
but he decided that well i think i'm
gonna cut
one of your hands because that's another
thing that you do
so he chased her around with a knife and
cut the tendons
on in one of her hands and then later on
that like a couple months later he also
like took her hand and impaled it with a
knife
on the kitchen table after she said oh
my hand's kind of stiff and then he was
like
conk yeah hey did that fix it and then
he decided later he's like you know
i think that whole arm has to come off
what
he took a [ __ ] meat cleaver and cut
her [ __ ]
arm off damn did that kill her no she's
still alive
like i said i saw an interview with her
yeah and she has no arm
he cut her [ __ ] arm
i think it was i think it was here all
right i think it was at the
yeah damn and then she laid there
bleeding yeah and then they stitched it
up the next morning
damn now uh obviously this poor
woman gabrielle she runs she runs away
with one [ __ ] arm
well he didn't stop him before he did
that i get well i think he surprised her
i think he just was just kind of like
hey i decided you don't need an arm chop
damn that's like i said it's like a auto
left
left [ __ ] a long time ago anyway
that's a [ __ ] horror movie
i kind of have to i kind of have to
admit that uh
i can understand the [ __ ] the cult
ideology that cult dynamic
can get a grip on people over time but
i don't i wouldn't stood for that no way
i don't know how he did this
they must have i think they had like
stockholm syndrome at this point
and and they may have not have been
there may have not have been
all that with it even when this started
i mean
so they probably started off kind of i
don't want to say dumb but let's just
say naive
well like i said i think what happens
too it's the same thing that you see
happen
it's a similar kind of dynamic that
happens in like abusive relationships
and it's like sometimes you get into
this thing you know that in the
beginning they call it like the
honeymoon period or whatever it's the
same thing with cults or
you know abusive relationships or
whatever you get into it like the people
like super nice and it's like
everything's awesome
like at the beginning yeah love bombing
they do that as well
and then like just very very slowly it
starts getting more and more horrific
and it's almost kind of like you don't
notice
yeah because you're just like you get so
used to everything and as it ratchets up
it doesn't like alarm you because it's
not going from like
you know love bombing to
cutting someone's arm off in one single
day
that takes like a really long time to do
that i mean you have to think he started
the cult in 1977 the arm cutting off
didn't happen until 1989.
so you know what i mean so these people
had been with him for a long time and i
think that a lot of them even later
said that they were like well when he
wasn't drunk
he was like all right like he was a nice
person get drunk cut your arm off but
he'd get drunk
man you got to watch him when he gets
drunk he'll cut your arm off i'd have
[ __ ] that dude up
oh [ __ ] man i mean
that guy's obviously a maniac yeah i
mean
i mean and the fact that he got away
with it for so [ __ ] long
since poor woman has her arm cut off
they stitched it up for the next day gee
thank you
and it's like she uh actually managed to
escape with one arm so
you know hero so she hitchhikes to a
hospital
and uh at the hospital she finally told
them what the [ __ ] was going on there
so they finally like raid the place and
arrest this [ __ ] right
now he at the time he pleads guilty to
three counts of aggravated assault one
count of unlawfully causing bodily harm
which seems a little
you know it seems just i don't know it
just doesn't seem like
to capture the gravity of what he did
really
but he got uh 12 years in prison
um but then they were talking to other
people that were in the cult that were
by this point they were like yeah that's
that's enough of this [ __ ] right
um so another cult member led them to
where solange's
body was the woman that he had killed by
the guts by cutting her guts out and
then jerking off into her skull
uh so when they found that body then
they were like okay well then they tried
him for
second degree murder and then he got
sentenced to life in prison
uh so what ends up happening with this
this is probably a very fitting
end for this [ __ ] so he did go
to prison
february 26 2011 not that long ago just
10 years ago
uh rock therio who was then 63 years old
they found him dead in his cell at
dorchester penitentiary
what ended up happening was that his
cellmate which was a dude named matthew
mcdonald who was 60
he was also a convicted murderer and he
he had a life sentence
um he stabbed
rock in the neck with a shiv walked to
the guard station
handed them the shiv and said quote
that piece of [ __ ] is down on the range
here's the knife
i've sliced him up okay so
even though that dude is a murderer i
think he did the world of [ __ ]
service
well the guy did it did it probably
going home anyway well no he already had
a life sentence yes it didn't matter and
like i said that dude was his cellmate
and he was probably like sick of that
dude so he's like you know what i'm just
gonna stab you right in the [ __ ]
throat
and i'm just gonna say i did it look
there i did it he's gone what could they
do to him i mean
exactly yeah so that's what i'm saying
so
good riddance and thank you for your
service
matthew mcdonald even though you were
also probably a piece of [ __ ] murderer
but good job there good job well like i
said if you're gonna
if you're gonna like murder some people
do some dexter [ __ ] do that kind of [ __ ]
kill that guy because that guy for sure
probably didn't have anything to do with
deserve to be [ __ ] [ __ ]
probably didn't have to do anything to
do with what the dude did it was
probably
just a personal conflict between the two
though so
you know what i mean yeah he got his
issue maybe he just thought he was
annoying yeah
because i feel like that dude or
something i didn't know
i didn't know rock therio but from
ethereum but everything that i've heard
about him
like from other people he seemed like
one of those insufferable
yeah he thought he not only thought he
was smarter than everyone else
which as far as i could tell like went
back to when he was a kid
could not think that [ __ ] though could
he nope
okay pookie's asking me to go outside oh
poor put your collar on put your clothes
on pokey
you're not going out with no clothes on
what happened oh she's like oh my god
yeah mango said i like this cell mate i
like that too well i like the fact that
he
you know the cool thing about it was
that i like that he just stabbed the
dude and then he just went to the guard
station's like yep
stab the dude there we go
you know and they were probably just
kind of like i mean i think i got he got
another life sentence piled on top of
that but he's like [ __ ] it i already had
a life sentence why do i care
but like i said i don't know if it was
because he just thought he was a piece
of [ __ ] or
you know because of what he did or
because he just like pissed him off one
day and he was just like [ __ ] i'm not
putting up with this [ __ ]
anymore
it could have been you know why not both
but yeah you know it just seems like a
good a good thing to do like i said if
you're gonna murder somebody
do some dexter [ __ ] like that because
that was uh that was pretty cool i don't
know if that dude's still alive or not
because he was uh let's see what was he
he was 60
so he'd be 70 now he might be still
alive i don't know
so like i said they did do a film about
this
case which like i said i'm surprised
this isn't better known because
i mean if anything like cutting off a
woman's arm
cutting a two-year-old kid's penis in
half or whatever the [ __ ] he did
jerking off inside a dead woman's skull
and pulling her guts
i mean [ __ ] man you can't make this [ __ ]
up
and i'm surprised it's like not better
known so i was like i was reading the
wikipedia page like going you've got to
be [ __ ] kidding
me holy [ __ ] but yeah so they did make a
movie about it called savage messiah
um it came out in 2002 but i think it
was just like a french language film i
think it's available on youtube because
i'm pretty sure i saw it like up there
for free but i didn't have time to watch
it like before the [ __ ] because i kind
of wanted to see it
but um but i guess it's kind of based on
the book there's a book called that also
that one of the um that somebody wrote
and also
uh gabrielle lavalay who was the woman
that got her arm cut off
uh she also wrote about the cult
um and her book is called alliance of
the sheep at least that's the
english title i can't pronounce the
french title but
she um there's a couple documentaries
about them and like she was interviewed
on there as well but like i said she's
the one that got her arm cut off and she
actually did escape
so she wrote a book about the cult as
well so
that's uh also really interesting yeah
it says says [ __ ] how gore filled with
that film be right that's what i was
thinking it was like something i was
like that's some [ __ ] hostile [ __ ]
right there
jerking off in people's skulls and like
talking to jesus during a religious
ceremony jesus christ trying to
resurrect them
pull their guts out and like [ __ ] put
molasses up their ass i mean like who
the [ __ ] even thinks of that
who even thinks of that i don't know i
can't imagine like i said
i'd um i don't know
dahmer versus raiders roomies in a
prison cell who'd win
raider raider was a lot bigger than
dahmer
summer was kind of weak and wiry wait
raider was pretty strong
well in dumber it was kind of more like
i'm gonna like put people to sleep and
then
like inject windex into their brains
yeah
he didn't he didn't dara wasn't violent
per se he wasn't
he just wanted the body yeah he didn't
care about killing the person he didn't
get off on killing the person he just
wanted the body
he wasn't even very mean he was target
oriented yeah
he just wanted the body he'd drug you
knock you out
do something to you while you were
knocked out try to turn you into a sex
zombie
if it wouldn't work and then he'd knock
you back out and strangle you to death
he wasn't into like direct confrontation
or suffering
raider was he was hands on
well raiders um he got his sexual kicks
from
struggling and fighting watching people
struggle and like watching people being
afraid of talking to him doing power
trips yeah
he was he was a different kind of like a
power
rapist yeah
even though to look at him he just looks
like a schlub yeah
well he wanted to be a cop he couldn't
make it as a as a cop
this but he could make it as a dog
catcher type thing and
an officer figure out how yeah because
grandpa's just talking about he's a
retired cop
he'd meas he says he'd he'd [ __ ] be
jerking off and trying to kill you and
measuring grass at the same time and
stuff
he was a his friend said he was a
stickler
any little thing he'd try to stickle you
stickle the [ __ ] out of you about you
know oh well no it's got to be your
grass has got to be you know
he followed all kinds of made you follow
all kind of rules
he followed rules too but when you
weren't looking he'd
strangle some woman he'd strangle her
and then take her to the church and take
pictures of the body
bury himself you know in [ __ ] women's
underwear taking pictures of himself
with a woman's mask
[ __ ] creepy man creepy it is pretty
clear well you know man gotta express
himself you know
he's [ __ ] you know if that's all he
was doing and he wasn't killing people
no one would care no he's a murderer
yeah it's like if you want to just like
dress up in women's clothes and take
your pictures of yourselves in the dirt
then that's
you know you do you whatever but it's
like don't [ __ ] kill people to do
that [ __ ]
shouldn't need to be based on the photos
i saw just things that he said
in some weird way he saw the female
victim as an extension of himself
and in a way he felt like he was maybe
killing himself so he was kind of
also wanted to live wanted to see
things through the eyes of the victim
that's why he would dress up in women's
pantyhose and put the face on and tie
himself up and put himself in the grave
kind of like so he could feel what it
was like or something
yeah he seemed to get off both angles
it's weird because
he really seemed to in a lot of ways he
seemed to objectify
women in the sense that he didn't see
them as people necessarily maybe he did
his wife and daughter but everyone else
no way
um but the weird thing too is that he
also seemed to
identify with the victim like he wanted
to he wanted to play
both roles yeah i think the women that
he was killing he kind of
in a way wanted to be them at the same
time
he wanted to be him and them at the same
time in the act
so it was kind of a what was his name
albert fish was like that it's
sadomasochism
he yeah he enjoyed inflicting pain but
he also liked
wanted it wanted and wanted to inflict
pain on himself like hey i'm going to
stick needles in my
taint yeah because he was you know he
wanted to be the perpetrator and the
victim
yeah which like i guess that's the thing
but you know like i said it's just a
weird
it was a broad it was a [ __ ]
broadband he was a wide spectrum he
wanted
a wide spectrum [ __ ] offender
he wanted the pleasure and pain he
wanted
to be the killer and he wanted to have
guilt for it and then he wanted to atone
for the guilt that's the way
that's the way a fish was
he thought he was jesus he was jesus and
the devil
he was acting this way i mean anytime
anybody thinks they're jesus you're just
heading for trouble
jesus and the devil he was that's really
devil inflicting the evil and he was
jesus [ __ ]
taking it and [ __ ] becoming you know
enlightened and paying for the sins of
mankind and
so you have a real self-aggrandizement
that he how
important he is you know he's very
important
and so the only person that would ever
fantasize about that kind of [ __ ]
is a nobody you're not important that's
why you're
that's why you lust to be that important
yeah i mean you just can't be regular or
you just can't be cool you can't
you got to be on a cosmic level that's
that's kind of what they're doing
i feel like so many problems would be
solved if people would just get the [ __ ]
over you gotta get the [ __ ] over
yourself
get over yourself it's like everybody
like everybody has
value just as being a human but it's
like nobody nobody knows
every nobody has all the answers nobody
knew jesus nobody just [ __ ] calm down
man just be like normal
well i think i think uh fish one of the
reasons why
fish was so [ __ ] up was the time that
he lived in
it was a very low information society
so it's very easy to become isolated
and to maybe run away with yourself and
[ __ ] go off into your own little
[ __ ]
world you know without having outside
perspectives come in because you could
isolate yourself
yeah can't really do that social media
is stopping a lot of this stuff i think
even though social media causes a lot of
stupid [ __ ]
causes a lot of [ __ ] mass [ __ ]
hysteria
and almost like they can manipulate you
through it you know through algorithms i
mean you know there's been
whole doctors come out and say this [ __ ]
is dangerous man they can manipulate
your perspective
your perspective of reality through
algorithms
but there's also a lot of good [ __ ] that
it does
yeah you find out that there's another
people like you you know you're you know
how you relate to other people
yeah and in fish's time they didn't have
that
um it was a pretty bad [ __ ] all they
had was newspapers maybe some radio
and boy when you listen to what they
were listening to and reading what they
were
reading those old articles there wasn't
a lot there by today's standards not
much
it was all kind of heavily filtered
[ __ ] i mean
what's what's a dude that wants to eat
his own poop and stick needles into his
taint to do
i mean he doesn't have any wonder
there's no meetups yeah there's no
facebook there's no instagram
what's he gonna do he doesn't even know
there's a name for that
he doesn't know there's a name for that
and he doesn't have anybody else to talk
to about his interests
well what happened was that he went down
a rabbit hole on his own
without any understanding so he
developed along those lines he went down
that path
in a world where that just wasn't
around so he assumes his insanity he's
assumes he's insane so he goes even
crazier
you get worse i think see now that's
that's another thing and i think we've
discussed this before
i think the problem and i one of the
things like i said i know everybody
likes to piss and moan about like oh
social media and it's like blah blah but
i don't know to me to me it just seems
like it seems like
it's a tool it could be used for good or
evil i'm not super worried about it i i
don't like all this like kind of
decrying it because i'm like you sound
like all the
grandmas back in the old days that said
[ __ ] about oh my god the [ __ ]
the moving pictures ah you know it's
causing all these problems so it just
sounds like that to me
yeah but there's a different perspective
that you have well no no no but i'm just
saying that one of the good things that
i think
that has come about is that now if you
have like some
weird proclivity i'm not saying violent
proclivities because [ __ ] those people
but like people that have just like
weird
fetishes or whatever it's like you can
find someone else online that has the
same [ __ ] as you and you can talk to
that person and you can talk about that
kind of [ __ ]
and it can be normalized to an extent
where it's you don't
have to just go down this
you don't have to go inward um and
just go into the spiral of i'm the only
person in the world that feels like this
and i must be there must be something
wrong with me i'm [ __ ] up
and then like the more you go down that
road like the more likely it is
that you're gonna act out and do some
[ __ ] albert fish [ __ ]
so i think it's good that people can
like talk to other people it's like
hey i like to eat my own [ __ ] too or
whatever it is that they're
into it's like i'm not into that that's
[ __ ] gross but like
you know you can meet other people and
they're like you know it's weird and
but you're not gonna kill anybody you
know what i'm saying
yeah to defend what i said about social
media
i didn't jenny might have misportrayed
what i was saying
each we don't have free social media
nobody kind of really does each
civilization the chinese
japanese western civilization europe
they all kind of have their own
platforms that they're going through
like we're going through mostly google
chinese has their own firewalls so each
one of these markets has their own
perspective
of reality based upon what
servers and you know or what what
services they're using
and how those services are controlled i
don't like any of that
i think it should be a free-for-all i
think
there should be the internet should be
wide open
and a bunch of different [ __ ]
platforms there shouldn't be any
centralized control
it should be a wide open network
that way you yourself can
choose the social media you want to be
in and access all information and you
can come up
with your own view of the world instead
of having a viewpoint shoved down your
throat
i don't believe in any kind of
centralized propaganda that's what
television was and cable
and we should be getting away from that
i believe in an open network
you know an open network of information
i don't believe in a chinese firewall
they should be seeing the same internet
we're seeing but the thing about it is
that
i mean the thing about it though is that
you know you can say that we have this
on the other thing but there's ways to
get around all this oh yeah there it is
so it so it's way better than it is but
yeah it's much better than you
the the problem right now is fake mostly
just facebook twitter and youtube
there are now new alternatives coming
they can't they shouldn't
in the before we were channeled just
through those
and you had to follow those rules which
is kind of like a monopolies in a way
there should be there should be
competitors where you can go
to all these other places which that's
happening now
um it was the same problem it's a
temporary problem
all right it was the same problem we
have there with the railroads
back before the highway system here in
the united states the railroads were the
most powerful organization inside the
united states
they can make or break a town they could
destroy an entire town
by stopping by by not stopping at your
town
you know because that's what was
bringing all the supplies and all the
people
so the railroads were extremely powerful
they were killing people the railroads
there's a lot of weird [ __ ] they had
their own private army
they had their own court system that
could pass the death sentence
on [ __ ] on on
on people that worked for them on
employees
because the united states couldn't do it
you know [ __ ] they were back in
washington dc they couldn't project any
power
and they were operating in places where
states didn't really exist yet just like
frontier areas
so the railroads handled [ __ ]
business and they handled it badly
according to according to the evidence
along the sides of where those railroads
you'd find sometimes mass graves that
are a hundred and something years old
like what happened here
all these damn chinese and irish
skeletons [ __ ] in massive graves
they probably just suppressed a rioter
revolt and it was never
recorded just mowed them all down you
know it's kind of like the east india
company
bad you know so we're in a situation a
little bit like that not quite as
violent
but chet i don't like monopolies
corporations the government's supposed
to protect you from corporations
corporations can do bad [ __ ]
and have a long history of doing bad
[ __ ]
but um yeah we done with this
um case yeah all right
i think so yeah yeah you took your wig
off when did you do that oh man i got
hot
god i took that off i got i got sick of
looking like harpoon marks
you just needed one of those
like a little horn that you can like
blow so has anybody got any questions
let me see
they're saying like people are saying
they're agreeing with me man i would
like
i wore a wig like the whole show and
sometimes i wear wigs like the whole
night that we go out and he can't even
wear one for like an hour and he's like
man it was too hot i had to take it off
figures
[Laughter]
oh my god yeah there's a child
mineworker's grave about 30 miles from
me says xanada yeah
yeah man they used to make all those
little kids go down in the mines
because they were small yeah they want
me to put on a michael landed wig
yeah we don't have a michael landon wig
we'll get one one of these days you
could be you could be like a little
house on the prairie dad
yeah and other people are mentioning
that those weird reformed schools and
weird reform schools where they tortured
kids
uh you know what i mean or molested kids
and then they [ __ ] vanished you find
[ __ ] graves there that was weird they
did a lot of weird [ __ ] throughout
throughout history
well i think we mentioned that before
it's just kind of like i don't
think i mean i think it's a pretty
modern concept that like
everybody had like every individual has
like some value i think but i think for
a long time people are just like yeah
these [ __ ]
poor people or whatever you can just
[ __ ] blow them all down and hey
what's funny is that shit's not [ __ ]
ancient i mean it's just come
out now there's a big problem in germany
the the german government since the 80s
was basically selling orphans to [ __ ]
pedos that's just
thousands and thousands of them that's
come out there was almost cause a damn
revolt that's in germany
just there was corruption throughout the
entire system there was weird corruption
throughout history with the orphanages
too
yep so things haven't changed really
i think the ability to find it is a lot
easier though well like i said i think
in that way at least
it seems a lot better yeah because at
least well at least one people are more
aware of it and two
people realize that that's [ __ ] up
yeah that that shouldn't happen
yeah even if it feels like he can't do
anything about it i mean
but you know a hundred years ago no one
would have been just like
oh well oh well who cares but evidently
if you look at the history of people
that were
what they call nowadays in the
politically correct terms minor
attracted
they will [ __ ] got involved in those
industries they got involved in those
businesses to have access to kids
and evidently going back hundreds of
years they were selling them out the
back door ain't that something
ain't that some [ __ ] you'd think you'd
hear more about that though
as the kids grew up you think they would
talk
yeah you might think but evidently it
was going on yeah
so you want to go and shut it down yeah
i reckon so yeah graham through hammer
says melissa gilbert who played uh half
pint or
you know laura ingalls on little house
in the prairie yeah lives near me in
livingston county michigan
he married an actor from here named
timothy busfield i've heard of timothy
busfield he was in a bunch of [ __ ] i
have to look up his imdb didn't know
but i know that name but so yeah living
there in michigan
i used to love little house in the
prayer i don't know the books and
everything when i was little
cool show at least tom rock the wig
tonight i'm gonna go check out
976 evil one of these days i want to do
i don't know if i want to do a
retrospective on that i liked that movie
because it had
like robert england directed it yeah and
then uh stephen jeffries from fright
night was in it
which i was into but i remember watching
it back in the day and i was just kind
of like
that's not really that good but i don't
know i haven't seen it in a long time so
it might be good and i just might be
forgetting
you know what i mean they did actually
on um the
the documentary in search of darkness
too they did have um
robert england on there and he was
talking a little bit about that movie
so maybe i'll give it another watch
because he seemed excited about it
what are you doing you're knocking my
light out no i put that glass
out of the way so pookie wouldn't run
into it yeah
hey i give that film a shout out a
couple of streams back um
so what so she wouldn't [ __ ] with it
yeah okay
i had that glass canted up against the
wall and i realized that she couldn't
see that she might run into that one
oh yeah don't let her do that yeah
grandpa said he was in 30 something oh
yeah yeah that's right
okay yeah i remember that i don't think
i ever like really watched that show but
i was kind of like aware of it
all right so i guess we covered
everything i'm really glad the stream
did drop again i was really really
worried because it dropped after [ __ ]
20 minutes that was a long show
it was yeah we were almost at three
hours and plus we had like 20 minutes
from the other
thing but like i said i think i'm going
to relabel that one just like
pre-show okay because we didn't really
get to the topic like on that one
we were just talking about going to
chantelles and why not yeah all right so
that'll do it for episode 247
we'll be back on sunday afternoon
probably be talking about elvis and
nixon we might talk about another movie
as well if we watch another one in the
meantime
yeah go watch elvis and nixon it's uh
you can get it on it's a good movie
yeah yeah yeah accurate yeah and then
like i said
we might we might talk about another one
too just if we watch another one we'll
see how it goes
all right so thank you everybody for
dropping by as always
thanks for donations everybody donated
and we will see you guys
on sunday afternoon have a good
weekend bye